The Kokomo on which the sun rose on July 4th was not the same Kokomo on which the orb of day set at the close of America's 147th birthday. Kokomo had had an awakening, a spiritual awakening. It had witnessed the spectacle of 200,000 men and women, filled with patriotism and love of country, one-fifth of a million men and women who, by their attendance, signified their belief in a living Christ and an open Bible. Journey from points afar to be present at a vast meeting wherein there were to be no carnival features, sporting events, circus stunts, or spectacular events. It saw staunch American farmers with their wives, merchants of repute,
7月4日黎明时的科科莫，与美国147岁生日结束时日落下的科科莫已截然不同。科科莫经历了一场觉醒，一场精神上的觉醒。它见证了20万男女的壮观场面，他们心中充满了爱国主义和对国家的热爱；这20万男女通过他们的出席，表达了他们对活着的基督和开放的《圣经》的信仰。他们从远方赶来，参加一场没有狂欢活动、体育赛事、马戏表演或壮观演出的盛大集会。它看到了坚定的美国农民和他们的妻子、声誉卓著的商人、
bankers of integrity, honest and hard-working mechanics, doctors and men of all professions, leaders in their communities, ministers and devout church workers, in fact, men and women from every walk of life. Today, Kokomo made, may well boast that she has royally entertained the biggest crowd of 100% red-blooded Americans
正直的银行家、诚实勤劳的机械师、医生和各行各业的人士、社区领袖、牧师和虔诚的教会工作者，事实上，是来自社会各阶层的男男女女。今天，科科莫可以自豪地说，她隆重地接待了美国历史上在同一时间、同一地点聚集的规模最大、最纯粹的美国人，
that ever assembled at any one place at any one time in the history of America to do homage to God, the flag and the home. So stirring stuff there in the newspaper, The Fiery Cross, which was public, in Indianapolis on the 13th of July 1923, and it's describing an enormous Independence Day picnic. And I'm guessing, Dominic, from the name of that newspaper, The Fiery Cross, that the Ku Klux Klan may have something to do with this. Yeah, you're not wrong, Tom.
他们聚集在一起，向神、国旗和家庭致敬。报纸《火十字》在1923年7月13日于印第安纳波利斯公开发表了这些令人振奋的内容，它描述的是一场盛大的独立日野餐。多米尼克，从《火十字》这个报纸名称来看，我猜三K党可能与此有关。是的，汤姆，你没猜错。
So this picnic was one of many bizarre and extraordinary episodes in the history of the second Ku Klux Klan, which we'll be talking about today. So last time, to give people a bit of a reminder, we talked about how the clan was reborn thanks to Thomas Dixon's book and play, The Clansman, the film, The Birth of a Nation, and the vision of a man called William J. Simmons, who wanted to basically make money by inventing his own fraternal order. Dominic, can I just ask, did Thomas Dixon join the clan? No.
所以这场野餐是第二代三K党历史上许多离奇而超凡的事件之一，我们今天将讨论这个话题。为了让大家回顾一下，上次我们谈到了三K党是如何在托马斯·狄克逊的书和剧作《族人》、电影《一个国家的诞生》以及一个名叫威廉·J·西蒙斯的男人的愿景下重生的，他想通过发明自己的兄弟会来赚钱。多米尼克，我能问一下，托马斯·狄克逊加入三K党了吗？没有。
He just sat there and enjoyed his money. No, Thomas Dixon had made all this money from the book and the play, but he didn't approve of the second clan. He condemned it. Interesting. That's a twist. Yeah, I think basically because he'd been shut out was part of it. But also, he condemned it as peddling hatred, which for the man who written the book, The Klansman, it's a bit rich.
他只是坐在那里享受他的钱。不，托马斯·狄克逊从书和剧作中赚了很多钱，但他并不赞同第二代三K党。他谴责了它。有趣。这真是一个转折。是的，我想主要是因为他被排挤在外了。但同时，他也谴责它是在兜售仇恨，对于写出《族人》这本书的人来说，这有点讽刺。
It seemed a bit rich. But he didn't like the attacks on Catholics and Jews, interestingly. He thought that was poor from the clan. Anyway, so it was transformed. Simmons's attempt to basically make money by setting up a rival to the Masons, were transformed by two PR and marketing experts, Edward Young Clark. and Elizabeth Tyler, who we talked about last time, who launched this massive sales operation and a message of 100% Americanism, basically a defense of white Protestant America
这听起来确实有点讽刺。但有趣的是，他不喜欢针对天主教徒和犹太人的攻击。他认为三K党的这种做法很糟糕。总之，它被改造了。西蒙斯试图通过建立一个与共济会竞争的组织来赚钱，但被两位公关和营销专家爱德华·杨·克拉克和伊丽莎白·泰勒改造了，我们上次谈到过他们，他们发起了大规模的销售行动，并提出了“100%美国主义”的口号，本质上是捍卫白人新教徒的美国，
against African Americans, but more importantly, Jews and above all Catholics. It was a huge hit, exploited the mood of anxiety at the end of the First World War, anxiety about immigration, about immorality, the big debate about prohibition, and it attracts at its peak maybe four million people, five million people. And we ended last time with the clan making big gains in the 1922 elections, sort of endorsing and campaigning for candidates for governor and winning lots of seats in state legislatures, and sending the first clan sort of open clan senator to the United States Congress from the state of Texas.
反对非裔美国人，但更重要的是反对犹太人，尤其是天主教徒。这非常成功，利用了第一次世界大战结束后人们焦虑的情绪，对移民的焦虑、对道德沦丧的焦虑，以及关于禁酒令的大辩论，它在巅峰时期吸引了大约四百万到五百万人。上次我们结束时提到，三K党在1922年的选举中取得了巨大进展，支持并为州长候选人竞选，在州议会中赢得了许多席位，并从德克萨斯州向美国国会输送了第一位公开的三K党参议员。
So we have now moved on six months. The Kokomo picnic takes place in Indiana. And Indiana is a state that will play a big part in today's episode, because in the mid-1920s, this is the supreme clan stronghold. And the story of the clan in Indiana is absolutely bizarre and it ends with a really lurid and strange murder scandal, which will come to in the second half. But just on this picnic, the article in the Fiery Cross says 200,000 people. This is maybe an exaggeration, but even the lowest estimates reckon that there are at least 50,000 people there. There were special trains chartered by the clan to bring people from neighbouring
现在时间过去了六个月。科科莫野餐在印第安纳州举行。印第安纳州将在今天的节目中扮演重要角色，因为在20世纪20年代中期，这里是三K党的最高堡垒。三K党在印第安纳州的故事极其离奇，并以一桩非常耸人听闻且奇怪的谋杀丑闻告终，我们将在下半部分讲到。但就这次野餐而言，《火十字》的文章说有20万人。这可能有些夸张，但即使是最低的估计也认为至少有5万人参加。三K党包租了专列，从邻近的
states. The lines of picnic tables were longer than entire street blocks. And the report is actually disingenuous. The report said people were not drawn by carnival features, sporting events or circus stunts. This is not true. There was a kids area, a special kids area of the picnic. Well, the clan loved dressing up as clowns, don't they? Yeah, kids would love that. There was a boxing ring. There were choirs. There were circus performers. They had a big screen and they screen talkies, you know, films.
州运送人们。野餐桌的行列比整个街区还要长。而且这份报道实际上是不诚实的。报道称人们不是被狂欢活动、体育赛事或马戏表演吸引来的。这不是真的。野餐现场有一个儿童区，一个专门的儿童区。嗯，三K党喜欢打扮成小丑，不是吗？是的，孩子们会喜欢那个。那里有一个拳击台。有唱诗班。有马戏团表演者。他们有一个大屏幕，播放有声电影。
There was a plane circling overhead with a great flashing white cross. And get this, an acrobat standing on the plane doing stunts on the wing of the plane. God, who wouldn't want to see that? Of course you'd want to go and see that. Now, here's the mad thing. This was very, very typical of clan events in the mid-1920s. So they would hold hundreds of similar events all over America. They'd have barbecues, they have parades, that'd have baseball tournaments, and they'd have
头顶上有一架飞机盘旋，上面有一个巨大的闪烁的白色十字架。还有，一个杂技演员站在飞机上，在机翼上表演特技。天哪，谁不想看那个？你当然想去看。现在，疯狂的事情来了。这在20世纪20年代中期三K党的活动中非常非常典型。他们在全美各地举办了数百场类似的活动。他们有烧烤、游行、棒球锦标赛，还有
these great picnics. They'd be advertised in the newspapers. They'd be heavily promoted by Methodist ministers in their sermons. They'd say, you know, go to the Kokomo picnic. Lots of God-fearing Americans will be there. And tens of thousands of people would go to these things. So it's weirdly, it's a kind of prefiguring of Woodstock in the 60s. Really?
这些盛大的野餐。它们会在报纸上做广告。卫理公会牧师会在布道中大力宣传。他们会说，去参加科科莫野餐吧。许多敬畏上帝的美国人都会在那里。成千上万的人会参加这些活动。所以奇怪的是，这有点像是60年代伍德斯托克音乐节的预演。真的吗？
I mean, that kind of idea of people turning in. up in, you know, to have huge kind of festivals, large crowds. I mean, obviously the, the vibe is very different. The vibe is different. But it's so often, things that seem distinctive about the 60s are being prefigured in kind of unsettling ways. I guess so. Yeah. I think what it takes inspiration from a lot is sort of state fairs. Have you ever been to one of these state fairs? No. I went to the Minnesota state fair once. Is it fun? I probably wouldn't go again deep down. I mean, mainly a lot of it seems to be eating these horrendous snacks, kind of corn dogs or whatever. But the idea of turning up in an enormous field and having a great festival.
我是说，那种人们聚集在一起参加大型节日、大规模人群的想法。显然，氛围非常不同。氛围确实不同。但通常情况下，60年代看似独特的现象，往往以令人不安的方式被预演过。我想是这样。是的。我认为它在很大程度上借鉴了州博览会。你去过这种州博览会吗？没有。我曾经去过明尼苏达州博览会。好玩吗？我可能不会再去了。我的意思是，大部分内容似乎就是吃那些可怕的零食，比如玉米热狗之类的。但在巨大的田野里参加盛大的节日，这种想法……
Yeah, Americans love that. That's a thing, isn't it? Yeah, totally it is. But this, I mean, this did not happen at Woodstock. The Kokomo picnic, like most of these picnics, they will end with a cross burning on a hilltop. And there would be searchlights and flare. Sometimes there'd be fireworks. And these are great spectacles.
是的，美国人喜欢那样。那是一回事，不是吗？是的，完全是。但这并没有在伍德斯托克发生。科科莫野餐，像大多数这类野餐一样，以山顶上的十字架焚烧仪式结束。会有探照灯和照明弹。有时会有烟花。这些都是盛大的奇观。
I mean, they're very expensive. But they pay for themselves because they're... great for recruitment. So there will be hundreds, if not thousands of people who will join the clan en masse on these occasions. And your point about, you know, woodstock and festivals and whatnot, this is the side of the clan that I think would surprise listeners who think of, well, the clan is obviously a hateful paramilitary organisation. This is the clan as family fun, as a fun day out. So actually, if you live in Oregon or you live in Indiana or somewhere, and you have kids and you're white and you're Protestant.
我的意思是，它们非常昂贵。但它们能收回成本，因为它们非常有利于招募成员。所以会有成百上千，甚至上万人在此类场合集体加入三K党。关于你提到的伍德斯托克和节日之类的，我认为这是三K党会让听众感到惊讶的一面，因为人们认为三K党显然是一个充满仇恨的准军事组织。这是作为家庭娱乐、作为愉快的一天出游的三K党。所以实际上，如果你住在俄勒冈州或印第安纳州，你有孩子，而且你是白人、新教徒。
Going to one of these clan picnics, you know, it's a fun way to spend the day. And it's part of this huge social calendar. So the historian, social historian, Kathleen Blee, says, with the myriad of weddings, baby christenings, family picnics, athletic contests, parades, spelling bees, beauty contests, rodeos and circuses, the clan basically became, and I quote, an ordinary normal, taken for granted part of the life of the white Protestant majority. And when historians later did interviews with clan members, the thing that the clan members
去参加这些三K党野餐，你知道，这是度过一天的一种有趣方式。它是庞大社交日程的一部分。所以社会历史学家凯瑟琳·布利说，随着无数的婚礼、婴儿洗礼、家庭野餐、体育比赛、游行、拼字比赛、选美比赛、牛仔竞技表演和马戏团，三K党基本上成为了，引用她的话，“白人新教徒多数派生活中普通、正常、理所当然的一部分”。当历史学家后来采访三K党成员时，那些
from the 20s and were to about millions of people often said was, it was just, it was good fun. It was a laugh. We went along and people dressed up and there were circus stunts and there was sizzling burgers. I mean, this is wholesome fun rather than the castrating people and throwing them into the lake. Well, there's always that element, of course, to life in the clan. I don't want to undersell that element at all. But I think it is important to emphasise that it's not just about vigilante violence. So another aspect of this, which will surprise people, is how many women are involved.
来自20年代、人数达数百万的成员经常说，这只是好玩。这很有趣。我们一起去，人们打扮起来，有马戏表演，还有滋滋作响的汉堡。我的意思是，这是健康的乐趣，而不是阉割人并把他们扔进湖里。嗯，当然，三K党的生活中总是有那一面。我一点也不想淡化那一面。但我认为强调它不仅仅是关于私刑暴力很重要。所以这方面的另一个方面，会让人们感到惊讶的是，有多少女性参与其中。
So there's a historian called Linda Gordon, who's written a lot about this. She reckons about half a million women join the clan. Do they get costumes? They do get costumes, yeah. Now, this is not really surprising because women have always been very prominent in activist groups in American history. So some of the groups that basically fed into the clan,
有一位名叫琳达·戈登的历史学家，她写了很多关于这个话题的文章。她估计大约有五十万女性加入了三K党。她们有服装吗？她们确实有服装，是的。这并不令人惊讶，因为女性在美国历史上的激进组织中一直非常突出。所以一些基本上融入了三K党的组织，
so anti-immigration, eugenics, temperance, the anti-saloon league, these kinds of groups. Women were always a huge element of those groups. And at first, here's the amazing thing.
比如反移民、优生学、禁酒运动、反沙龙联盟，这些类型的组织。女性一直是这些组织的重要组成部分。起初，令人惊奇的是，
At first, women weren't allowed to join the clan, so they set up their own kind of unofficial groups. And then the men were like, oh, well, we can't have the ladies setting up their own unofficial groups.
起初，女性不被允许加入三K党，所以她们建立了自己非官方的组织。然后男人们说，哦，好吧，我们不能让女士们建立她们自己的非官方组织。
We'll have to set up our proper ones. So they set up the queens of the golden mask and the ladies of the invisible empire, and then they merge them all eventually into the women of the Ku Klux Klan. The women generally, as it's so often the way, the women did most of the work. So they basically did the party planning. They organized the picnics. They did all the transport. They did all the catering and all of that kind of thing. But it wasn't just a kind of women's places in the home organisation. The clan supported women's right to vote and to work. it's the modernity of clans women that's so striking.
我们必须建立我们自己的正规组织。所以他们建立了“金面具女王”和“隐形帝国女士”，最终将她们全部合并为“三K党女性”。女性通常，就像经常发生的那样，承担了大部分工作。所以她们基本上负责派对策划。她们组织野餐。她们负责所有的交通。她们负责所有的餐饮等等。但这不仅仅是一个“女性应待在家里”的组织。三K党支持女性投票和工作的权利。三K党女性的现代性是如此引人注目。
So Linda Gordon, give us an example of this woman called Daisy Barr, who was from Indiana, and she was in her mid-forties in the early 1920s. She came from a Quaker family. She had actually been a Quaker pastor before the First World War, so that was not unknown. And she was a colossal do-gooder. She was the president of the Indiana Humane Society, a campaigner for prohibition. She founded the Muncie Indiana YWCA. She founded a home for fallen women.
所以琳达·戈登给了我们一个例子，这个女人叫黛西·巴尔，她来自印第安纳州，在20世纪20年代初她四十多岁。她来自一个贵格会家庭。在第一次世界大战之前，她实际上是一位贵格会牧师，所以这并不罕见。她是一个巨大的慈善家。她是印第安纳州人道协会的主席，禁酒运动的倡导者。她创立了曼西印第安纳州基督教女青年会（YWCA）。她为堕落女性建立了一个家园。
She was the president of the Indiana War Mothers. She was the first female vice chair of the Republican State Committee. So she's one of those women, we all know people like this, who does everything, first to volunteer, you know, high-minded, home for fallen women, you know, YWCA, all of that. And does she, does she get awarded a brilliant title as a reward? She was the imperial empress of the queens of the golden mask. You don't get that with the Quakers. Yeah. And she became the chief clan recruiter for eight Midwestern and border states.
她是印第安纳州战争母亲协会的主席。她是共和党州委员会的第一位女性副主席。所以她是那种我们都认识的人，什么都做，总是第一个志愿服务，你知道，思想高尚，为堕落女性建立家园，你知道，基督教女青年会，所有这些。她是否因为奖励而获得了一个辉煌的头衔？她是“金面具女王”的帝国皇后。你在贵格会里可得不到那个。是的。她成为了八个中西部和边境州的三K党首席招募员。
So she's also making a bit of money on the side from the recruiting. And the thing, you look at someone like that and you say, well, is she far right? Because the clan, we perceive the clan as being far right. Or is she a progressive person with her interest in, you know, saving for women and women and setting up, you know, Christian groups and all this kind of thing. And the truth, of course, is that she's both and neither, that neither of these labels is enough to encompass her. They're both inadequate ways to capture the complexity of the politics of some of these people who joined the clan in the 1920s. That said, there is probably a danger of over-emphasizing the family-friendly normality of the clan. So Thomas Pigham, another historian, gives an example of another kind of fair appearance, which is the Texas State Fair in October 1923.
所以她也通过招募赚了一些外快。你看像她这样的人，你会说，她是极右翼吗？因为我们认为三K党是极右翼。或者她是一个进步人士，对拯救女性、建立基督教团体等感兴趣。当然，事实是她既是也不是，这两个标签都不足以涵盖她。它们都是不足以捕捉这些在20世纪20年代加入三K党的人的政治复杂性的方式。话虽如此，过度强调三K党的家庭友好常态化可能存在危险。所以另一位历史学家托马斯·皮格姆给出了另一个博览会露面的例子，即1923年10月的德克萨斯州博览会。
and at the Texas State Fair, a whole day was designated as Clan Day, and it was organized by Clan No. 66 of Dallas. And the flyer, I found the flyer online, gives it sets a very jolly tone. Meet your friends, Couguag's Clan Day, winners initiation of the largest class in the history of clandum, spectacular fireworks display, mass band concert, competitive drills by the women of the Ku Klux Klan drill team. You and your friends are invited to attend this,
在德克萨斯州博览会上，整整一天被指定为“三K党日”，由达拉斯第66号三K党分部组织。我在网上找到了传单，它定下了一个非常欢乐的基调。结识你的朋友，参加三K党日，获胜者将参加三K党历史上最大规模的入会仪式，壮观的烟花表演，大型乐队音乐会，三K党女性演练队的竞技演练。邀请你和你的朋友参加这个，
the most wonderful day of your life. I mean, imagine if it was. Yeah, there can't be accused of underselling it. No. 150,000 people went to this. 150,000 people. And there were clan-themed rodeos and bands and all of this, hot dogs, you name it. But the clan that had organized at clan number 66 was one of the most violent in the country.
你一生中最美妙的一天。我的意思是，想象一下如果真是那样。是的，他们不能被指责为夸大其词。不。15万人参加了这次活动。15万人。还有以三K党为主题的牛仔竞技表演、乐队等等，热狗，应有尽有。但组织这次活动的第66号三K党分部是全国最暴力的分部之一。
It had a reputation for kidnapping and flogging people. Is this the one with the flogging field? The flocking field in Dallas. the flocking meadow, exactly. And one of its alumni was a guy called Hiram Evans, who we'll be talking about later. He had led some of these beatings. He is now the Imperial Wizard, and he gives a blood-curdling speech at this occasion. He describes African Americans as savage. He describes Jews as alien and money-mad. And above all, he says, Catholics pose the greatest danger to our institutions because they belong to a corrupt church that thrives upon ignorance. And he is saying this
它以绑架和鞭打人而闻名。这就是那个有鞭打场的吗？达拉斯的鞭打草地，没错。它的校友之一是一个叫海勒姆·埃文斯的人，我们稍后会谈到他。他曾领导过一些殴打事件。他现在是帝国巫师，他在这个场合发表了令人毛骨悚然的演讲。他称非裔美国人为野蛮人。他称犹太人为外来者和金钱狂。最重要的是，他说，天主教徒对我们的制度构成了最大的危险，因为他们属于一个在无知中茁壮成长的腐败教会。他正在对
these 150,000 people who are eating their hot dogs and enjoying the rodeos and whatnot. In other words, the racist bigotry and the threat of violence is never that far away, even at the most apparently anodyne, you know, wholesome, family-friendly outing. And this issue of violence, I mean, American historians have kind of really got stuck into each other about just how violent the clan was and how important to it. Basically, it depends on what state you look at. So historians who've looked at southern states, which were already very violent. often really emphasize how important violence was.
这15万正在吃热狗、享受牛仔竞技表演的人说这些话。换句话说，种族主义偏见和暴力威胁从未远离，即使是在最看似无害、健康的家庭友好郊游中也是如此。关于暴力的问题，我的意思是，美国历史学家们真的在争论三K党到底有多暴力以及它有多重要。基本上，这取决于你观察哪个州。所以研究南方各州的历史学家，那些州本来就非常暴力，通常真的强调暴力有多重要。
So Nancy McLean writing about Georgia or Glenn Feldman writing about Alabama. But then there are other historians who say, are you not maybe over exaggerating this? For example, it's an odd thing. People associate the clan with lynching. Do you not think, Tom, when people think about the clan, they think about lynching? Yeah, absolutely. But lynching actually peaked in the 20th century before the clan ever grew. It peaked in 1919 and then declined at precise to the point when the clan is rising.
所以南希·麦克莱恩写关于佐治亚州的文章，或者格伦·费尔德曼写关于阿拉巴马州的文章。但也有其他历史学家说，你们是不是有点夸大其词了？例如，这是一件奇怪的事情。人们将三K党与私刑联系起来。汤姆，当人们想到三K党时，你不认为他们会想到私刑吗？是的，绝对。但私刑实际上在20世纪三K党发展之前就达到了顶峰。它在1919年达到顶峰，然后在三K党崛起时反而下降了。
Is that because they're all off having their hot dogs and things? I think it's because lynching and the clan are two different things. Most clan violence is nocturnal. It's vigilante violence later night. Lynchings, I mean, as shocking as it will seem to most of our listeners, are open, public occasions, carried out in broad daylight. Nobody wears masks. The openness is part of the point.
这是因为他们都去吃热狗了吗？我认为这是因为私刑和三K党是两回事。大多数三K党暴力是夜间的。这是深夜的私刑暴力。私刑，我的意思是，尽管对我们大多数听众来说这看起来很令人震惊，但它们是公开的、公共的场合，在光天化日之下进行。没有人戴面具。公开性是重点的一部分。
It's a sort of public collective ritual, a lynching, as horrific as it may be. Now, that doesn't mean that we should downpriced. play clan violence completely, and let's get into some of this violence. So by the mid-1920s, especially in the northern states, it is becoming a really serious issue because there's a lot of violence against Catholic groups. So there's a rival to the clan among the Catholics called the Knights of Columbus. The Knights of Columbus has been founded in 1882, so it's older than the clan. But it fought back quite vigorously. I mean, they have a similar, you know, like all these fraternal orders, they have secret passwords and handshakes and signs and
私刑是一种公共的集体仪式，尽管它可能很可怕。现在，这并不意味着我们应该完全低估三K党的暴力，让我们进入一些暴力事件。所以到了20世纪20年代中期，特别是在北部各州，这正成为一个非常严重的问题，因为有很多针对天主教团体的暴力。所以天主教徒中有一个与三K党竞争的组织，叫哥伦布骑士会。哥伦布骑士会成立于1882年，所以它比三K党更古老。但它进行了相当有力的反击。我的意思是，他们有类似的，你知道，像所有这些兄弟会一样，他们有秘密密码、握手和标志以及
stuff. But they fight back and there were brawls in a lot of Midwestern states, open brawls, even gunfights. So Lily, Pennsylvania in 1924, fighting between hundreds of clansmen and locals and Knights of Columbus and whatnot ends with this kind of street battle, which there's gunfire across the street. Three people end up being shot in the crossfire and so on. And in some places, the paramilitary dimension definitely gets out of control. And this brings me to the state of Illinois, Midwestern state. So the clan was established in Illinois in 1921. It got lots of members in Chicago, but it did really well downstate in southern Illinois in the rural counties. It had hundreds of individual lodges or Clavons downstate, and it had these enormous outdoor rallies.
东西。但他们进行了反击，在中西部许多州发生了斗殴，公开的斗殴，甚至是枪战。所以1924年的宾夕法尼亚州莉莉，数百名三K党成员与当地人和哥伦布骑士会成员之间的战斗，以这种街头战斗告终，街头有枪声。三个人在交火中被枪杀等等。在某些地方，准军事维度绝对失控了。这让我想到伊利诺伊州，中西部的一个州。所以三K党于1921年在伊利诺伊州成立。它在芝加哥有很多成员，但在伊利诺伊州南部的农村县做得非常好。它在南部有数百个独立的分会，并举行了这些巨大的户外集会。
And in one county in particular, if you listened last week, we were talking about York County, South Carolina, where the first clan became entrenched. And one of its equivalents in the 1920s is a place called Williamson County in Illinois. So in Williamson County, that's at the very southern tip of Illinois. So far down, you might as well be in Kentucky or Tennessee. And it's a coal mining country. It's already an unhappy place because there's been lots of strikes and labor unrest, violence between unions and strike breakers. And the other thing about Williamson County that's so interesting is loads of European immigrants have moved in.
特别是在一个县，如果你听了上周的节目，我们谈到了南卡罗来纳州的约克县，第一个三K党在那里扎根。而20世纪20年代它的对应物之一是伊利诺伊州的威廉姆森县。所以威廉姆森县位于伊利诺伊州的最南端。太靠南了，你还不如在肯塔基州或田纳西州。这是一个煤矿区。这已经是一个不快乐的地方，因为有很多罢工和劳工动荡，工会和罢工破坏者之间的暴力。关于威廉姆森县另一个非常有趣的事情是，大量的欧洲移民搬了进来。
So a fifth of the population is now Catholic, and these tend to be Italians from Lombardy, they're Lombards. And there's lots of local anxiety about Catholicism and saloons and prostitution and all of this kind of thing. So it's perfect territory for the clan. And the clan arrived in an absolutely typical style. They marched in in their robes to the first Christian church of Marion, and they handed over three fresh, $10 bills to the minister. and the minister held up the dollar bills to his flock, and he said, that tells you they stand for something good. And so everybody joined the clan, or at least a lot of people did,
所以五分之一的人口现在是天主教徒，他们往往是来自伦巴第的意大利人，他们是伦巴第人。当地对天主教、沙龙、卖淫等有很多焦虑。所以这是三K党的完美领地。三K党以绝对典型的风格到达。他们穿着长袍游行进入马里昂的第一基督教会，并向牧师递交了三张崭新的10美元钞票。牧师向他的信众举起美元钞票，他说，这告诉你们他们代表着美好的事物。于是每个人都加入了三K党，或者至少很多人加入了，
and the clan held these big open-air meetings with burning crosses, and they said, we have come here to clean up the county and to purge vice and whatnot. But the bloke they got to lead their crusade was a very violent man. He was called S. Glenn Young, and he'd formerly worked for the Justice Department, but he'd been kicked out of his prohibition units for basically excessive zeal. And he forms paramilitary squads of Klansmen, and they basically launch raids across Williamson County. And they take hundreds of people prisoner, because they're working in cahoots with the kind of local cops.
三K党举行了这些大型露天会议，焚烧十字架，他们说，我们来到这里是为了清理这个县，清除罪恶等等。但他们找来领导这场十字军东征的人是一个非常暴力的人。他叫S·格伦·杨，他曾为司法部工作，但因基本上过度热心而被踢出了禁酒部门。他组建了三K党准军事小队，他们基本上在威廉姆森县发动了突袭。他们俘虏了数百人，因为他们与当地警察勾结。
He and his Klansmen take hundreds of prisoners and herd them back in kind of chain gangs to the town jails. He starts to wear a military uniform. He carries two handguns. He sometimes carries a machine gun. They will beat up their prisoners. They will attack immigrants. They attacked so many French and Italian people in their homes that the local consuls of both countries launched formal protests to the US government about the way their citizens were being treated. Eventually, the Illinois state authorities sent in the National Guard to restore order. Young was arrested for assault and battery, but he and his bodyguards, when they went to court. They went to court with their machine guns, like holding their machine guns, and they were promptly acquitted. I mean, that is one way to get off the charge. So at this point, the state authorities flooded the county with National Guardsmen to try to basically clamp down on the clan. David Chalmers puts it, before the whole episode was over, practically every prominent man in the county, judges, policemen, sheriffs, mayors, county supervisors and states its
他和他的三K党成员抓了数百名囚犯，并将他们像链条帮一样赶回城镇监狱。他开始穿军装。他带着两把手枪。他有时带着机关枪。他们会殴打囚犯。他们会攻击移民。他们袭击了太多法国和意大利人的家，以至于两国驻当地领事就其公民受到的对待方式向美国政府提出了正式抗议。最终，伊利诺伊州当局派出了国民警卫队来恢复秩序。杨因殴打罪被捕，但他和他的保镖在去法庭时。他们带着机关枪去法庭，就像拿着机关枪一样，他们很快就被判无罪。我的意思是，这是摆脱指控的一种方式。此时，州当局用国民警卫队淹没了该县，试图基本上镇压三K党。正如大卫·查尔默斯所说，在整个事件结束之前，该县几乎所有显赫的人物，法官、警察、警长、市长、县主管和州检察官
is came under indictment for conspiracy, kidnapping, assault, malfeasance, riot or murder. Guardsmen with fixed bayonets and emplaced machine guns became a part of everyday life. This is an insane thing to happen in this county in the middle of nowhere. By the spring of 1924, it's basically become a complete war zone. This guy young and his men are utterly out of control. It's like a Caldeo in South America, traveling around with hordes of machine gun totes. bodyguards. So it's quite like that county in the first episode. Yeah, York County, South Carolina. Yeah, the one where I went in and cleaned it up. Oh, Major Merrill, Major Lewis Merrill. Yeah.
都因阴谋、绑架、殴打、渎职、骚乱或谋杀而被起诉。带着固定刺刀和部署机关枪的警卫成为日常生活的一部分。这在荒郊野外的这个县发生是一件疯狂的事情。到1924年春天，它基本上变成了一个完全的战区。这个叫杨的家伙和他的手下完全失控了。这就像南美洲的考迪罗，带着成群结队的机关枪保镖到处走。所以这很像第一集里的那个县。是的，南卡罗来纳州的约克县。是的，我进去清理它的那个。哦，梅里尔少校，刘易斯·梅里尔少校。是的。
Presumably, they can't, the federal government cannot bring order to everywhere where the clan are running riot. I guess so. I mean, in this case, it's National Guard that are sent in, and they do eventually do it, but it takes years. The American system, you're so dependent on local authorities. Yeah, that if they get corrupted, it's a kind of... That they get corrupted, what can you do? And this is the story of the American South in the first half of the 20th century. Yeah. What can you do? I mean, the showdown is beyond parody. Basically, Young had a gunfight in this mining town with a bootleggar called Charlie Berger. They had a final sort of, you know, once upon a time in the West-style confrontation
据推测，联邦政府无法在三K党横行霸道的每一个地方恢复秩序。我想是这样。我的意思是，在这种情况下，派出了国民警卫队，他们最终做到了，但这花了几年时间。美国制度，你太依赖地方当局了。是的，如果他们腐败了，这是一种……他们腐败了，你能做什么？这就是20世纪上半叶美国南方的故事。是的。你能做什么？我的意思是，摊牌简直是滑稽的。基本上，杨在这个矿业城镇与一个叫查理·伯格的私酒贩子发生了枪战。他们进行了一场最后的，你知道，像《西部往事》风格的对抗，
in a soft drinks parlour. Of course, it's prohibition. Even though this guy's a bootlegger. I don't know. What's he doing in the soft drinks parlour? Maybe he's just having a milkshake. A soda. Sure, step away from the beverage fountain. Yum. Well, anyway, this bootlegger and Young, the paramilitary, they opened fire at each other at the same point. The bootlegger was shot but survived, but Young was shot and killed. His funeral in the county was a huge clan occasion. 40,000 people went to his funeral, and he was interred in a special mausoleum with a clan on a guard.
在一家软饮料店。当然，这是禁酒令时期。尽管这家伙是个私酒贩子。我不知道。他在软饮料店做什么？也许他只是在喝奶昔。苏打水。当然，远离饮料喷泉。杨。好吧，无论如何，这个私酒贩子和杨，那个准军事人员，他们在同一时间向对方开火。私酒贩子中弹但幸存下来，但杨中弹身亡。他在该县的葬礼是一个巨大的三K党场合。4万人参加了他的葬礼，他被安葬在一个有三K党守卫的特殊陵墓中。
Initially at first, men with machine guns stood by his tomb, sort of day and night. I mean, do you think they're still there? Surely not. I don't know. Anyway, all of this is very bad publicity for the clan. But actually, what's going on inside the higher echelons of the clan is equally terrible publicity. So to recap, Tom, you will recall that after the summer of 1920, the clan was effectively led by three people. So there's this guy who looks like the Northamptonshire lawyer.
起初，拿着机关枪的人日夜守在他的墓前。我的意思是，你认为他们还在那里吗？肯定不在了。我不知道。无论如何，所有这些对三K党来说都是非常糟糕的宣传。但实际上，三K党高层内部发生的事情同样是可怕的宣传。所以回顾一下，汤姆，你会记得在1920年夏天之后，三K党实际上由三个人领导。所以有这个看起来像北安普敦郡律师的家伙。
Yeah, garter salesman. Dr. Saliseman. William J. Simmons. The guy who basically hired the bus and taken his friends up the mountain and set some planks on fire. And then there's the couple who were found in bed with a bottle of whiskey. Yeah. Edward Young Clark and Elizabeth Tyler. And Elizabeth Tyler looks like Queen Victoria. Yes. They bonded over a publicity campaign for eugenics. And now we're running the Southern Publicity Association. They sound a fun couple. So these three people between them had made loads of money from the clan. But by 1921, the regional leaders of the clan were plotting against them.
是的，吊袜带推销员。萨利斯曼医生。威廉·J·西蒙斯。那个基本上租了公共汽车，带着朋友上山，点燃了一些木板的家伙。然后是那对被发现躺在床上，身边有一瓶威士忌的夫妇。是的。爱德华·杨·克拉克和伊丽莎白·泰勒。伊丽莎白·泰勒看起来像维多利亚女王。是的。他们因优生学宣传活动而结缘。现在我们正在经营南方宣传协会。他们听起来是一对有趣的夫妇。所以这三个人从三K党那里赚了很多钱。但到了1921年，三K党的区域领导人正在密谋反对他们。
Are these the goblins? Goblins. Exactly. Goblins. So you can never trust a goblin. They'll always get you in the end. So basically, the goblins gripes are as follows. First of all, they say these three people have paid a ton of money from the clan,
这些是妖精吗？妖精。没错。妖精。所以你永远不能相信妖精。他们最终总会抓住你的。所以基本上，妖精们的抱怨如下。首先，他们说这三个人从三K党那里拿走了大量的钱，
and it's not right, and we should have some of their money. They are very displeased about these two people being caught in bed with a bottle of whiskey. And they've lost confidence in the imperial. real wizard. That's a terrible thing to have happened. Yeah. Again, it's this whole Wizard of Oz thing. Well, like the Wizard of Oz, he's too old. It's old fashioned. The more go-ahead members of the clan think he looks like a relic in his frock coat and his kind of pouncenae glasses. Worse, he's been known to hang around at horse
这不对，我们应该分到他们的一些钱。他们对这两个人被发现躺在床上，身边有一瓶威士忌感到非常不满。他们对帝国巫师失去了信心。那是一件可怕的事情。是的。同样，这是整个《绿野仙踪》的事情。嗯，像《绿野仙踪》一样，他太老了。这太老套了。三K党中更有进取心的成员认为他穿着礼服大衣和那种夹鼻眼镜，看起来像个遗迹。更糟糕的是，众所周知他经常在赛马场
races drinking. And given the clan's commitment to prohibition, this is very poor from William Simmons. So at the end of 1921, four grand goblins. Went to Atlanta. Went to Atlanta. Four. Four grand goins.
喝酒。鉴于三K党对禁酒令的承诺，威廉·西蒙斯的这种做法非常糟糕。所以1921年底，四个大妖精。去了亚特兰大。去了亚特兰大。四个。四个大妖精。
Yeah. Imagine going into a railway carriage and finding this four grand goblins. Four grand gobbins have gone to Atlanta and they have a showdown with Simmons and they say,
是的。想象一下走进一节火车车厢，发现这四个大妖精。四个大妖精去了亚特兰大，他们与西蒙斯摊牌，他们说，
you've got to fire these people, Clark and Tyler. They're cooking the books, the hands in the till, which is almost certainly true. They're skimming off loads of money. Get rid. After a lot of pressure,
你必须解雇这些人，克拉克和泰勒。他们在做假账，手伸进了钱柜，这几乎肯定是事实。他们正在挪用大量的钱。滚蛋。在巨大的压力下，
Mrs. Tyler is the first to go. She says she's exhausted. She needs some to spend time with her daughter. Actually, she's almost certainly been embezzling money. And then what happens? At the end of May 1922, William J. Simmons, the original founder of the second clan, says he's going to take a sabbatical from the clan.
泰勒夫人是第一个离开的。她说她精疲力竭。她需要一些时间陪伴她的女儿。实际上，她几乎肯定一直在挪用公款。然后发生了什么？1922年5月底，第二代三K党的创始人威廉·J·西蒙斯说他要从三K党休假。
He's been ill and he needs to rest. Actually, he's been drinking and he needs to dry out. So he's going to take a break. And in his absence, the sole surviving member of the PR partnership, who's Edward Young Clark, will be the acting imperial wizard. Now, what follows is a bit tangled, so prepare yourselves, and it makes Stalin's court seem friendly and easygoing.
他病了，需要休息。实际上，他一直在喝酒，需要戒酒。所以他要休息一下。在他缺席期间，公关合伙关系中唯一幸存的成员，即爱德华·杨·克拉克，将担任代理帝国巫师。现在，接下来发生的事情有点纠缠不清，所以做好准备，这让斯大林的宫廷看起来都很友好和随和。
Clark, the PR man, is now the acting imperial wizard, but he needs allies to run the clan. And his chief ally is the head of the clan's secretariat, who is called Hiram Wesley Evans. So we've met him before, haven't we? He's popping up all over the place, giving rants, mad rants, I mentioned Stalin and I said he was the head of the clan's secretariat and people who know
克拉克，那个公关人员，现在是代理帝国巫师，但他需要盟友来管理三K党。他的主要盟友是三K党秘书处的负责人，名叫海勒姆·韦斯利·埃文斯。所以我们之前见过他，不是吗？他到处出现，发表咆哮，疯狂的咆哮，我提到了斯大林，我说他是三K党秘书处的负责人，那些了解
about the rise of Stalin and how he was the basically in charge of all the membership lists will maybe guess what's coming. Hiram Evans was from Texas. He was the son of a judge. Unusually for a leading figure in the clan, he actually was well educated. But he ended up becoming a dentist and apparently a very mediocre dentist. His dental rivals dismissed him as a mere tooth puller. So his remedy for everything was just to pull out your teeth. But he didn't mind that the fact that he was mediocre. He leaned into it. He called himself the most average man in America. And this was part of his populist message. I'm an ordinary person. I will appeal to ordinary clansmen. So he's an every man. He looks, is medium height. He's chubby. He's soft spoken. Like a lot of clansmen,
斯大林崛起以及他如何基本上负责所有会员名单的人可能已经猜到接下来会发生什么。海勒姆·埃文斯来自德克萨斯州。他是一位法官的儿子。对于三K党的领导人物来说，这很不寻常，他实际上受过良好的教育。但他最终成为了一名牙医，而且显然是一位非常平庸的牙医。他的牙科竞争对手称他为“拔牙匠”。所以他解决一切问题的办法就是拔掉你的牙齿。但他并不介意他平庸的事实。他倾向于它。他称自己为“美国最普通的人”。这是他民粹主义信息的一部分。我是一个普通人。我会吸引普通的成员。所以他是一个普通人。他看起来，中等身材。他胖乎乎的。他说话轻声细语。像许多成员一样，
he's joined loads of different societies in lodges and stuff. But as so often in the story, there is a dark side. He is the guy who was the head of the Dallas Lodge. Oh, so the whipping meadow. The whipping the kidnappings. He'd been the bloke who'd been in charge of branding a man, which happened in the last episode, in acid on his head. So he is actually Stalin. Anyway, this dentist, Evans, Mrs. Tyler and Clark had basically recognized his ambition, and they'd brought him to run membership recruitment, and they paid him a lot of money. And he He used this to entrench his power and to win over a lot of the regional managers. Yes, very Stalin.
他加入了许多不同的社团和分会等等。但正如故事中经常出现的那样，有一个黑暗面。他就是达拉斯分会的负责人。哦，所以是鞭打草地。鞭打绑架。他就是那个负责给一个人打烙印的人，这发生在上一集，把酸倒在他的头上。所以他实际上就是斯大林。无论如何，这个牙医，埃文斯，泰勒夫人和克拉克基本上认可了他的野心，他们带他来负责会员招募，他们付给他很多钱。他利用这一点来巩固他的权力并赢得许多区域经理的支持。是的，非常斯大林。
Yeah, very Stalin. He is Stalin, basically. It's the American Stalin. And he, as time goes on, 1921, 1922, he says to the Grand Goblins, these PR people are corrupt. I should be running the clan. And he'd launched his coup, very Stalin style. Stalin would have launched his coup at the sort of Congress of some party Congress.
是的，非常斯大林。他基本上就是斯大林。这是美国的斯大林。随着时间的推移，1921年，1922年，他对大妖精们说，这些公关人员是腐败的。我应该管理三K党。他发动了他的政变，非常斯大林风格。斯大林会在某种党代会上发动政变。
This is what Hiram Evans does. It is the first annual convocation of the clan in Atlanta in November 1922. So Simmons, the founder, has just got back from sabbatical and resumed his position as Imperial Wizard. The night before the conference begins, Evans calls a meeting in his Atlanta hotel. And one of the people in the meeting is the rising star of the northern clan, who is the boss in Indiana, who is going to. called David C. Stevenson. Remember this man, David C. Stevenson. He will play a big part in the second
这就是海勒姆·埃文斯所做的。这是1922年11月在亚特兰大举行的三K党第一次年度会议。所以西蒙斯，创始人，刚刚从休假中回来并恢复了他的帝国巫师职位。会议开始的前一天晚上，埃文斯在亚特兰大的酒店召集了一次会议。参加会议的人之一是北部三K党的后起之秀，也就是印第安纳州的老板，他叫大卫·C·史蒂文森。记住这个人，大卫·C·史蒂文森。他将在第二
half. They get together, the Grand Goblins, these people, and they say, yeah, we're going to launch a coup against Simmons. And they go over to Simmons's house, which as you will record, is called Clan Crest. And at 3 a.m., they persuade Simmons to accept a promotion to emperor from Imperial Wizard. But what Simmons doesn't realize is the title of Emperor is utterly meaningless. he has secretly been stripped of his power. So Dominic, are prefiguring there of the series that we'll be doing after this, which is about 12th century Japan. Right.
部分扮演重要角色。他们聚在一起，大妖精们，这些人，他们说，是的，我们要对西蒙斯发动政变。他们去了西蒙斯的家，正如你所记得的，叫“三K党之巅”。凌晨3点，他们说服西蒙斯接受从帝国巫师晋升为皇帝。但西蒙斯没有意识到的是，皇帝这个头衔毫无意义。他已经被秘密剥夺了权力。所以多米尼克，这是我们之后要做的系列节目的预演，关于12世纪的日本。对。
And this is what happens to the emperors of Japan? The emperor's become ciphers, yes. Yeah, well, there you go. So basically, Simmons is kicked upstairs to become emperor, and Evans will become the new imperial wizard. And his ally, this guy Stevenson from the north, who will talk about in the second half, he becomes the sort of supremo in the north.
这就是日本天皇发生的事情吗？天皇变成了傀儡，是的。是的，好吧，给你。所以基本上，西蒙斯被踢上去当了皇帝，而埃文斯将成为新的帝国巫师。他的盟友，这个来自北方的史蒂文森，我们将在下半部分谈到，他成为了北方的最高统帅。
He gets a free hand in the north. The one person they still need to get rid of, though, is the other PR man, Edward Young Clark. He unfortunately has blotted his copybook further. First of all, he went to a prohibition offense, gave a speech about the evils of drink, got absolutely hammered. And they got hammered afterwards and was arrested for drunkenness. And secondly, he's just been indicted for violating the man act. What he has done, he's been accused of. of smuggling women across state lines for immoral purposes, because he had arranged for a young girl
他在北方获得了自由。然而，他们仍然需要摆脱的一个人是另一个公关人员，爱德华·杨·克拉克。他不幸进一步玷污了自己的名声。首先，他去参加了一个禁酒令违规活动，发表了一篇关于饮酒危害的演讲，结果喝得酩酊大醉。他们事后喝醉了，并因醉酒被捕。其次，他刚刚因违反《曼恩法案》被起诉。他所做的是，他被指控
who was the sister of a bank robber to travel, and I quote, to travel from Houston to New Orleans to assuage his loneliness. Right. As Imperial Wizard, Hiram Evans terminates this guy's contract, and then there's a year of demented legal infighting where Simmons and Clark, so the founders, try to set up their own rifle to the clan. There's a lot of fighting about copyright. And then in February 1924, Hiram Evans, the Stalin, the Texas Stalin dentist, he offers them a deal.
为了不道德的目的将女性偷运过州界，因为他安排了一个年轻女孩，她是银行劫匪的妹妹，去旅行，引用他的话，“从休斯顿旅行到新奥尔良以缓解他的孤独”。对。作为帝国巫师，海勒姆·埃文斯终止了这个家伙的合同，然后是一年的疯狂法律内斗，西蒙斯和克拉克，也就是创始人，试图建立他们自己的三K党竞争对手。关于版权有很多争斗。然后在1924年2月，海勒姆·埃文斯，那个斯大林，那个德克萨斯斯大林牙医，他给了他们一个交易。
He basically buys Simmons off, pays him $146,000. So this is the end of the founders of the clan. They basically fade from the scene. Simmons, the guy who had originally tried to relaunch the second clam, he retires. He tries to set up a new group called inevitably, the knights of the flaming sword, that's a failure and he dies. So this leaves the dentist,
他基本上把西蒙斯打发走了，付给他14.6万美元。所以这就是该组织创始人的终结。他们基本上从舞台上消失了。最初试图重启第二个三K党的西蒙斯退休了。他试图建立一个名为“烈焰之剑骑士团”的新组织，但以失败告终，随后他去世了。这让牙医，
Hiram Evans, in charge of the clan. This has been terrible publicity for them. I mean, the revelations of corruption and immorality in the newspapers, a lot of ordinary members are left very disillusioned. But Evans thinks he can take the clan to even greater heights. He's got big plans. He wants to clean up corruption. To do that, he puts the Klegals, the recruiters on salary, not on commission, so they'll behave better. He wants to clamp down on drinking in the clan. He says, come on. If we're the shocked troops of prohibition,
海勒姆·埃文斯接管了该组织。这对他们来说是极其糟糕的宣传。我的意思是，报纸上关于腐败和不道德行为的揭露，让许多普通成员感到非常幻灭。但埃文斯认为他能把该组织带向更高的高度。他有宏大的计划。他想清除腐败。为了做到这一点，他把克莱格尔（招募人员）改为领薪制，而不是佣金制，这样他们的行为会更规范。他想禁止组织内的饮酒行为。他说，拜托，如果我们是禁酒令的突击队，
we shouldn't be getting arrested all the time for drunkenness. He says the vigilante violence needs to be brought back under control. Klansmen should swear an oath to obey the law. But what he wants to do above all is to move into mainstream politics. He starts hiring Washington speechwriters and consultants. He starts, in clan propaganda, starts to say that the clan has a longer tradition in American politics than is generally thought. And they say their great hero is somebody who's been on the rest of history before.
我们就不应该总是因为醉酒而被捕。他说私刑暴力需要重新得到控制。三K党成员应该宣誓遵守法律。但他最想做的是进入主流政治。他开始聘请华盛顿的演讲撰稿人和顾问。他开始在组织的宣传中声称，该组织在美国政治中有着比人们普遍认为的更悠久的传统。他们说他们伟大的英雄是以前在《历史的其余部分》中出现过的人。
He's Uncle Jumbo, Big Steve. He's Grover Cleveland. Oh, it's great to have him back on the show. It's great to have him back on the show. So the clan hold him up and they say he's the kind of president we want. Why? What do they admire about him? I think there's various elements.
他是“大象叔叔”，大史蒂夫。他是格罗弗·克利夫兰。哦，很高兴他回到节目中。很高兴他回到节目中。所以三K党推崇他，说他就是我们想要的总统。为什么？他们钦佩他什么？我认为有各种各样的因素。
So Grover Cleveland was a Protestant. He liked German. Remember he was hanging out in German beer halls? and eating a lot of sausages. Yeah, so they like that. He'd cut a good figure to Clan Picnic. Also, Graverickin does kind of tick a Clan Box, in that there are enormous suspicions
格罗弗·克利夫兰是新教徒。他喜欢德国文化。记得他经常出入德国啤酒馆吗？还吃了很多香肠。是的，所以他们喜欢这一点。他在三K党野餐会上形象不错。此外，格罗弗·克利夫兰确实符合三K党的某些标准，因为人们对他与比自己年轻得多的女性之间的暧昧行为有巨大的怀疑。
about shady behaviour with women who are much younger than himself. Yes, of course, because he married his ward, didn't he? He married his ward. And, of course, there was the whole incident with Ma-Mah, Where's My Pa? Gone to the White House, ha, ha, ha, ha. So he kind of, although he had nothing to do with any clan,
是的，当然，因为他娶了他的被监护人，不是吗？他娶了他的被监护人。当然，还有关于“玛，我的爸爸在哪里？去白宫了，哈哈哈哈”的整个事件。所以，尽管他与任何三K党组织毫无关系，
you can kind of see why they might hold him up as an inspirational figure and a role model that they would want to follow. The maddest thing that Evans does, though, is he says we should move our headquarters to Washington so that we will be big kingmakers in national politics. And in order to fund the move, he sells the imperial palace in Atlanta to the Catholic Church. No. What a bombshell. What a twist. It is a twist. Now, the reason he has done that is because presidential elections are coming in 1924, and Evans wants to play The Kingmaker. However, there is a problem. There is a ticking time bomb at the heart of the clan.
你还是能看出为什么他们会把他视为一个鼓舞人心的人物和他们想要效仿的榜样。然而，埃文斯做的最疯狂的事情是，他说我们应该把总部搬到华盛顿，这样我们就能成为国家政治中举足轻重的造王者。为了资助这次搬迁，他把亚特兰大的帝国宫卖给了天主教会。不。真是个重磅炸弹。真是个反转。这确实是个反转。他之所以这样做，是因为1924年总统大选即将来临，埃文斯想扮演“造王者”的角色。然而，有一个问题。在三K党的核心，有一枚定时炸弹。
And this is his northern ally, the man I mentioned earlier, and I said to listeners, keep him in your heads. We'll come to him second half. He is the Grand Dragon of Indiana, David C. Stevenson. and he is about to become engulfed in the scandal to end all scandals, one of the weirdest and most shocking murders that we've ever done on the rest is history. Well, let's take a break and when we return, it will be with the murder of Madge Oberholzer. This episode is brought to you by Claude by Anthropic.
这就是他的北方盟友，我之前提到的那个人，我告诉听众，记住他。我们下半场会讲到他。他是印第安纳州的大龙，大卫·C·史蒂文森。他即将卷入一场终结所有丑闻的丑闻，这是我们在《历史的其余部分》中做过的最怪异、最令人震惊的谋杀案之一。好吧，让我们休息一下，回来后，我们将讲述玛奇·奥伯霍尔泽的谋杀案。本集由Anthropic的Claude赞助播出。
Now Tom, you and I, when we're together, we always argue about one thing, don't we? It's the existence or otherwise of the Loch Ness monster. But you foolishly are sceptical and you don't think that there is a monster beneath the freezing waters of that Scottish lock. Because as I know from AI, a plesiosaur would not be able to survive in Scottish waters because they'd just be too cold for it. Tom, this back and forth is what makes studying history so fun and actually Claude was made for this kind of thinking. The deep research feature can pull from dozens of sources at once. It can surface contradictions between them and it can give you a full breakdown. with citations so that you can trace the evidence yourself. It's like having a research partner
汤姆，你和我在一起时，总是争论一件事，不是吗？那就是尼斯湖水怪是否存在。但你愚蠢地持怀疑态度，不认为那个苏格兰湖冰冷的水下有怪物。因为正如我从人工智能那里了解到的，蛇颈龙无法在苏格兰水域生存，因为那里对它来说太冷了。汤姆，这种来回的辩论正是研究历史的乐趣所在，而且Claude就是为这种思考而生的。深度研究功能可以同时从几十个来源中提取信息。它可以揭示它们之间的矛盾，并为你提供完整的分析，并附上引文，这样你就可以自己追踪证据。这就像有一个研究伙伴，
who's read literally everything and wants to chat about what it actually means. So very like Dominic actually. Try Claude for free at clod.a.ai slash rest is history. Where are my gloves? Come on, heat. Any day now? Winter is hard, but your groceries don't have to be. This winter. winter, stay warm. Tap the banner to order your groceries online at walla.ca. Enjoy in-store prices without leaving your home. You'll find the same regular prices online as in-store.
他读过所有东西，并且想聊聊它到底意味着什么。实际上和多米尼克很像。在clod.a.ai/restishistory免费试用Claude。我的手套在哪里？快点，热起来。哪一天？冬天很艰难，但你的杂货不必如此。这个冬天，保持温暖。点击横幅在线订购杂货，网址是walla.ca。无需出门即可享受店内价格。你会发现网上的常规价格与店内相同。
Many promotions are available both in-store and online, though some may vary. Hello, everyone. Welcome back to The Rest is History. And Dominic, we promised you the murder of Madge Oberholzer, crazy and horrible way of death. And we'll be coming to her, weren't we? Yeah, absolutely bizarre. method of death that nobody could possibly anticipate. So in the second half of the state's episode, we're getting into the state of Indiana. This is the state where the clan was most embedded.
许多促销活动在店内和网上都有，尽管有些可能有所不同。大家好。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。多米尼克，我们答应过你要讲玛奇·奥伯霍尔泽的谋杀案，一种疯狂而可怕的死亡方式。我们会讲到她的，对吧？是的，绝对离奇。一种没人能预料到的死亡方式。所以，在这一集的下半部分，我们要进入印第安纳州。这是三K党渗透最深的州。
A quintessential middle American state, I'm guessing for loads of our listeners who are not American, they've probably never thought about the state of Indiana. They've never been there. It's just right in the middle of the United States. You don't really think about it. But it became by far the clan's most faithful heartland. It's very white. It's very Protestant. And for that reason, anti-Catholicism had long been a potent force in the state's public life. A lot of the histories of the clan tell this brilliant story as an example of how anti-catholic Indiana was. There was a place called North Manchester, and the preacher there said to his congregation one day, he was giving this sort of incredibly sort of rabble-rousing speech, and he said, search everywhere for hidden enemies,
一个典型的美国中部州，我猜对于我们许多非美国听众来说，他们可能从未想过印第安纳州。他们从未去过那里。它就在美国中部。你不会真的去想它。但它成为了三K党迄今为止最忠诚的大本营。它非常白人化。它非常新教化。因此，反天主教长期以来一直是该州公共生活中的一股强大力量。许多关于三K党的历史都讲述了这个精彩的故事，作为印第安纳州反天主教程度的一个例子。有一个叫北曼彻斯特的地方，那里的牧师有一天对他的会众说，他发表了一种极其煽动性的演讲，他说，到处搜寻隐藏的敌人，
vipers at the heart's blood of our sake of republic. Watch the trains. The Pope may even be on. on the northbound train tomorrow. And according to some of these histories, Adam, this surely must be a problem. A lot of people took this literally, in the next day there are a thousand people at the stage. Waiting for the northbound train. The train stopped on its way to Chicago.
我们共和国血液中的毒蛇。盯着火车。教皇明天甚至可能就在北上的火车上。根据其中一些历史记载，亚当，这肯定是个问题。很多人信以为真，第二天有上千人在车站等着。等着北上的火车。火车在去芝加哥的路上停了下来。
A bloke got off, and people grabbed him and mobbed him. It's the Pope. And actually, he was a man selling ladies corsets. That's what he said. Is that what the Pope would say if he came in disguise? If he's undercover, yeah. The idea that the Pope would go undercover to North Manchester, Indiana. I love it.
一个家伙下了车，人们抓住他并围攻他。是教皇！而实际上，他是一个卖女士紧身胸衣的人。他就是这么说的。如果教皇乔装打扮，他会这么说吗？如果他是卧底，是的。教皇会去印第安纳州北曼彻斯特当卧底的想法。我喜欢这个。
Anyway, the secret of the clan's success in Indiana is about individual political leadership and salesmanship. And this brings us to the last of the bizarre characters that have played a part in this story. And this is David C. Stevenson. And he's the northern leader who allied with the Texas dentist Hiram Evans to take control of the clan in 1922. And running through this story, actually, has been sort of weird parallels with the Great Gatsby. And David C. Stevenson is very, very J. Gatsby. He claimed to be the rich son of a millionaire businessman
总之，三K党在印第安纳州成功的秘诀在于个人的政治领导力和推销术。这就引出了在这个故事中扮演角色的最后一个怪异人物。这就是大卫·C·史蒂文森。他是与德克萨斯州牙医海勒姆·埃文斯结盟，在1922年夺取三K党控制权的北方领导人。贯穿这个故事的，实际上是一种与《了不起的盖茨比》奇怪的相似之处。大卫·C·史蒂文森非常、非常像杰·盖茨比。他声称自己是一位百万富翁商人的富有儿子，
who'd fought in the First World War and risen to become a major and been decorated for bravery and then made a fortune selling coal. This was totally untrue. He was the son of a poor sharecropper from Texas, born in 1891. He dropped out of school. He'd been a printer's apprentice in Oklahoma. He joined the army, but he never even got to Europe. He was a recruiter. He did sell coal, but as a
曾参加第一次世界大战，晋升为少校，因英勇表现获得勋章，然后通过卖煤发了财。这完全是谎言。他是德克萨斯州一个贫穷佃农的儿子，出生于1891年。他辍学了。他曾在俄克拉荷马州做过印刷学徒。他参了军，但甚至从未去过欧洲。他是一名招募员。他确实卖过煤，但作为一名
traveling salesman. I mean, a traveling coal salesman, that's a terrible thing to be. Anyway, that's what he was. He really does have a dark side. He's a very ruthless and unscrupulous and shady man. By the early 1920s, Stevenson has been married three times. He has a history of beating and abandoning his wives and of trying to sexually assault, rape other women. He's a stout man. he's always perfectly dressed, very conservatively. So he looks a kind of jolly, prosperous, successful man. So a kind of Uncle Jumbo vibe there then? A little bit, but I mean, Grover Cleveland, just to be clear,
旅行推销员。我的意思是，一个旅行卖煤的，那真是个糟糕的职业。总之，他就是那样的人。他确实有阴暗面。他是一个非常无情、不择手段且阴险的人。到1920年代初，史蒂文森已经结过三次婚。他有殴打和抛弃妻子，以及试图性侵、强奸其他女性的历史。他是个胖子，总是穿着得体，非常保守。所以他看起来像个快乐、富有、成功的人。那么有一种“大象叔叔”的氛围？有一点，但我的意思是，格罗弗·克利夫兰，为了清楚起见，
I think did we not quit Glover Cleveland of many of the charges? Yeah, we did, but he was fat and jolly. He was fat and jolly, yeah. This guy is fat and jolly as well, but in a sort of incredibly cede sinister way. He needs to find a vehicle for his talents. He's really got the gift of the gap. And Stevenson eventually makes a misstep. He runs for Congress as an anti-prohibition Democrat.
我想我们不是洗清了格罗弗·克利夫兰的许多指控吗？是的，我们洗清了，但他又胖又快乐。他确实又胖又快乐。这家伙也又胖又快乐，但以一种极其阴险的方式。他需要为自己的才华找到一个载体。他确实很有口才。史蒂文森最终犯了一个错误。他作为一名反禁酒令的民主党人竞选国会议员。
Oh, God. Rookies error. Mad error in Indiana. The Republicans absolutely hammer him. And so he switches to a pro-prohibition. And he joins the clan. And in early 1922, he becomes the clan boss in a place called Evans Town, Southern Indiana. And although he's only just turned 30, he's sort of master of sort of stunts.
哦，天哪。菜鸟错误。在印第安纳州犯了严重的错误。共和党人彻底击败了他。于是他转向支持禁酒令。他加入了三K党。1922年初，他成为了印第安纳州南部埃文斯镇的三K党头目。尽管他刚满30岁，但他是个搞噱头的大师。
gimmicks. So one of his gimmicks is he says to his cronies, never address me by my real name. Just call me the old man. It's like when Paul Inns, when he played for Manchester United, he insisted that people call him the governor. In this case, Stevenson insists that people call him the old man. He's a brilliant speaker, a rallies, doesn't know very well, and he turns the newsletter, the Fiery Cross into this weekly newspaper, and he recruited 9,000 paperboys to sell it across the Midwest. So is he the guy who's running that big festival that we began this episode with?
花招。所以他的花招之一是告诉他的亲信，永远不要用我的真名称呼我。只叫我“老人”。就像保罗·因斯在曼联踢球时，他坚持让人叫他“州长”。在这种情况下，史蒂文森坚持让人叫他“老人”。他是一位出色的演讲者，非常擅长集会，他把时事通讯《烈焰十字》变成了这份周报，并招募了9000名报童在整个中西部地区销售。那么他就是我们在本集开头提到的那个举办大型节日的人吗？
Yeah, he makes a dramatic entrance at the Kokomo picnic. Okay, great. So he's an incredibly successful recruiter and salesman. So in Southern Indiana, within a year, he is persuaded, and this is a staggering figure, one third of the entire adult white male population to join the clan.
是的，他在科科莫野餐会上戏剧性地登场。好的，太棒了。所以他是一位极其成功的招募员和推销员。因此，在印第安纳州南部，一年之内，他成功说服了——这是一个惊人的数字——整个成年白人男性人口的三分之一加入三K党。
Thousands of people joining every week. Huge parades. in all of these little towns, Fort Wayne, Crawfordsville, Jeffersonville, Winnamac and Coca-mole. And, you know, there'll be night parades with drums and all this kind. He's an expert and all this. Now, there is an element of vigilantism. Southern Indiana had a history of vigilantes that'd been, I didn't actually know this
每周都有成千上万的人加入。所有这些小镇都有盛大的游行，韦恩堡、克劳福兹维尔、杰斐逊维尔、威纳马克和科科莫。而且，你知道，会有带着鼓和所有这些东西的夜间游行。他是这方面的专家。现在，这里有一个私刑的成分。印第安纳州南部有私刑者的历史，我实际上并不知道这一点，
until reading up on this episode, there'd been a thing called the white capping movement in Indiana, vigilantes who acted as moral police. so they would go around targeting errant wives and lynching people who were suspected criminals and stuff. And Indiana still has a law that basically legalizes vigilantes. So county commissioners will swear in Klansmen as special constables. They have the right to bear arms and to arrest suspects. They will launch attacks on bootleggers. But they also organize mass boycotts of Jewish-owned businesses or Catholic shops and all of these kinds of things.
直到阅读这一集的相关资料，印第安纳州有一种叫“白帽运动”的东西，私刑者充当道德警察。所以他们会到处针对行为不端的妻子，并私刑处死那些被怀疑是罪犯的人等等。印第安纳州至今仍有一项法律基本上使私刑者合法化。所以县专员会宣誓让三K党成员担任特别警员。他们有权携带武器并逮捕嫌疑人。他们会对私酒贩子发动袭击。但他们也组织针对犹太人拥有的企业或天主教商店的大规模抵制活动，以及所有这些事情。
So there's that element to it, but that's not the whole essence of the clan in Indiana. There's a whole book about the Indiana clan by Leonard Moore called Citizen Clansman. Leonard Moore says, yes, there is violence, but there's an awful lot of barbecues and bake sales going on as well. That actually, as strange as it may seem, in sort of 1920, 1923, if you are an ordinary white Protestant, you join the clan in Indiana. It just becomes the thing that absolutely everybody does. they see it as an expression of their Protestant values and Protestant virtues. And the irony is the man at the top who's organized all this, who's profiting from it, is an absolute sheister and a crook and the complete antithesis of clean living family values.
所以这其中有那个成分，但这并不是印第安纳州三K党的全部本质。伦纳德·摩尔写了一本关于印第安纳州三K党的书，叫《公民三K党人》。伦纳德·摩尔说，是的，有暴力，但也有很多烧烤和烘焙义卖。实际上，尽管看起来很奇怪，在1920年、1923年左右，如果你是一个普通的白人新教徒，你就会在印第安纳州加入三K党。这简直成了每个人都会做的事情。他们将其视为新教价值观和美德的表达。讽刺的是，组织这一切、从中获利的人，是一个彻头彻尾的骗子和无赖，是清洁生活家庭价值观的完全对立面。
Because this is this guy, Stevenson. So Stevenson, he gets more and more successful. And his apotheosis comes at the Kokomo picnic. because the climax of that picnic is him being inaugurated as the grand dragon of Indiana. And it's already been a brilliant day. Remember, there's been all these buns and burgers. There's been a man doing stunts on a plane, right? All of that.
因为这就是这家伙，史蒂文森。所以史蒂文森越来越成功。他的巅峰是在科科莫野餐会上。因为那次野餐的高潮是他就任印第安纳州大龙。那已经是非常精彩的一天了。记得吗，有所有的面包和汉堡。有一个人在飞机上表演特技，对吧？所有这些。
And now you get to see a bloke become a dragon. Right. And another plane comes in from the south. And people are all excited. Who is it? Who is it? And the plane circles slowly. Then it lands in the field.
现在你可以看到一个家伙成为一条龙。对。另一架飞机从南方飞来。人们都很兴奋。是谁？是谁？飞机缓慢盘旋。然后降落在田野里。
Massive excitement. And this bloke Stevenson gets out and he's dressed in a silken purple robe. And he's escorted to the platform. And there's great cheers from the tens of thousands of people. And he raises his hand. And then he gives possibly the most shameless speech we've ever had on the rest of history. He says, my worthy subjects, citizens of the invisible empire, clansmen all, greetings. It grieves me to be late.
巨大的兴奋。这个叫史蒂文森的家伙走出来，穿着丝绸紫色长袍。他被护送到平台上。成千上万的人发出巨大的欢呼声。他举起手。然后他发表了可能是我们在《历史的其余部分》中听过的最无耻的演讲。他说，我尊贵的臣民，隐形帝国的公民，所有的三K党人，问候。我很抱歉迟到了。
The president of the United States kept me unduly long. counseling upon vital matters of state. I mean, how people are listening to this and believing it is mind-boggling. And then he says, Only my plea that this is the time and place of my coronation obtained for me surcease from his prayers for guidance. So the idea that this guy has been hanging out
美国总统让我待了太久，商讨国家大事。我的意思是，人们听着这些并相信它，真是令人难以置信。然后他说，只有我恳求这是我加冕的时间和地点，才让他停止了为我祈祷指引。所以这家伙一直和……
with who is the present at this point, I guess it's Calvin Coolidge, and I only managed to get away to attend the picnic at the last minute, would strike surely most people is laughable, but I guess a lot of people at the Kokomo picnic, like the idea that the Grand Dragon... Yeah, and he's their Grand Dragon. Yeah, it's not just anybody's Grand Dragon.
当时是谁在任，我想是卡尔文·柯立芝，我好不容易才脱身赶来参加野餐，这肯定会让大多数人觉得可笑，但我猜科科莫野餐会上的很多人，喜欢“大龙”这个想法……是的，他是他们的大龙。是的，不仅仅是谁的大龙。
He's Indiana's Grand Dragon. So he's now Supreme Leader in Indiana, and he's making a lot of money, and he's enjoying himself. He doesn't care about... I mean, don't forget he was an anti-prohibition Democrat initially. He doesn't give a damn about the politics. He's skimming off millions of dollars.
他是印第安纳州的大龙。所以他现在是印第安纳州的最高领导人，他赚了很多钱，他玩得很开心。他不在乎……我的意思是，别忘了，他最初是一个反禁酒令的民主党人。他根本不在乎政治。他正在从中捞取数百万美元。
He buys a summer house. He buys a yacht on Lake Erie. He has loads of congressmen around, very sort of Jay Gatsby behaviour. He's drinking all the time. But also, this is the thing that brings him down. He is a demented sexual predator. So the first thing that happens is he's caught in his Cadillac with his secretary with his pants down, to use the American expression. The police let him off, I think, on this occasion.
他买了一栋避暑别墅。他在伊利湖买了一艘游艇。他周围有很多国会议员，非常像杰·盖茨比的行为。他一直在喝酒。但这也是让他垮台的事情。他是一个疯狂的性掠夺者。所以发生的第一件事是，他被发现在他的凯迪拉克里，和他的秘书在一起，裤子脱了下来，用美国人的说法。我想警察这次放过了他。
Then he calls a manicurist to his hotel room and sexually assault her. And in the statement she gave later, she said, when she arrived to do his nails, he was already drunk. He said he would give me $100 if I would allow him to have intercourse with me. Of course, he was more rude than I care to be in expressing it. I told him, I was not in the habit of being insulted by anyone like that, and he said, you will or I'll kill you. This gives you a sense of the kind of man. Then in summer 1924, during another party, another woman went to the police, she said that during the party he locked her in the room, knocked her down, bit her and attempted to rape her.
然后他叫了一个美甲师到他的酒店房间，并性侵了她。在后来她提供的陈述中，她说，当她到达为他做指甲时，他已经喝醉了。他说如果我允许他与我发生性关系，他会给我100美元。当然，他表达得比我愿意表达的更粗鲁。我告诉他，我不习惯被任何人那样侮辱，他说，你必须这样做，否则我就杀了你。这让你了解了这种人。然后在1924年夏天，在另一次聚会上，另一名女性去了警察局，她说在聚会期间，他把她锁在房间里，把她打倒，咬她并试图强奸她。
And even at the picnic, he disgraces himself. He assaulted another woman afterwards, and she told investigators he is a beast when he is drunk. And again, he had tried to bite her, she said. So this will become a feature. Now, Stevenson, why is he doing all this? Partly because he thinks he can get away with it. He has now built this incredible political organization, which he nicknames the military machine. Every Indiana Clavern, Clan Lodge, will draw up data on every candidate for political office.
甚至在野餐会上，他也丢尽了脸。他事后袭击了另一名女性，她告诉调查人员，他喝醉时就是个野兽。而且，她说，他又试图咬她。所以这将成为一个特征。现在，史蒂文森，他为什么要这样做？部分原因是他认为他能逃脱惩罚。他现在已经建立了这个令人难以置信的政治组织，他称之为“军事机器”。每个印第安纳州的克拉文（三K党分会）都会整理印第安纳州每个政治候选人的数据。
in the state of Indiana, and the clan will sift through them all. And the data includes every opinion these people have ever expressed, their schools, their kids go to, their ethnic background, all of these kinds of things, what clubs they've joined. Then the clan makes its choice. The clan will then campaign for these people. They will get Protestant ministers to talk about them in their sermons. They will publish the approved slate in Sunday school newsletters. Klansmen will leave a special copy of the fiery cross telling you how to vote on your porch on election day. They have hundreds of cars ready to take Protestant voters to the polls. Clans women will stand ready to mind people's children so women can go and vote, all of this.
三K党会筛选所有这些数据。数据包括这些人曾经表达过的每一个观点、他们孩子上的学校、他们的种族背景、所有这些事情、他们加入的俱乐部。然后三K党做出选择。三K党随后会为这些人竞选。他们会请新教牧师在布道中谈论他们。他们会在主日学校的时事通讯中发布批准的名单。三K党成员会在选举日把一份特别的《烈焰十字》放在你的门廊上，告诉你如何投票。他们有数百辆车准备把新教选民送到投票站。三K党女性会准备好照顾人们的孩子，这样女性就可以去投票，所有这些。
And it's a brilliant success. It is an object lesson in how political organisation in kind of local America works. because in 1924, almost every single clan candidate in Indiana is elected to office, going all the way from mayors and district attorneys to sheriffs and school boards. And Stevenson thinks to himself, well, if I can do this in Indiana, I can do this anywhere. So in his headquarters in Indianapolis, he has a bust of Napoleon. He has eight phones, including one of them which he claims is a direct line to the White House, but no one has ever allowed to lift it because it's obviously just a complete fake.
这是一个巨大的成功。这是地方美国政治组织如何运作的一个典型案例。因为在1924年，印第安纳州几乎每一个三K党候选人都当选了，从市长和地区检察官到警长和学校董事会。史蒂文森心想，好吧，如果我能在印第安纳州做到这一点，我就能在任何地方做到这一点。所以在他位于印第安纳波利斯的总部，他有一个拿破仑的半身像。他有八部电话，其中一部他声称是通往白宫的直通线，但没人被允许拿起它，因为它显然只是个彻头彻尾的假货。
And Hicke says to his aides, I'm a nobody from nowhere, but I've got the biggest brains and I'm going to be the biggest man in the United States. And the first step to this is basically seizing control of the National Clan from the dentist. So in the summer of 1924, he declares independence from the National Clan, and he triggers this clan civil war. So it's basically Indiana is leading a revolt against Atlanta. There's a huge and very bizarre and Baroque struggle for power in which they're sort of suing each other for libel, Stevenson's local lodge is persuaded to kick him out. He accuses Hiram Evans of blowing up his yacht. I'm not sure how true that is.
他告诉他的助手，我是一个来自无名之地的无名小卒，但我有最大的头脑，我将成为美国最伟大的人。实现这一目标的第一步基本上是从牙医手中夺取全国三K党的控制权。因此，在1924年夏天，他宣布脱离全国三K党，并引发了这场三K党内战。所以基本上是印第安纳州领导了一场针对亚特兰大的反叛。这是一场巨大且非常怪异、巴洛克式的权力斗争，他们互相起诉诽谤，史蒂文森的当地分会被说服将他踢出。他指责海勒姆·埃文斯炸毁了他的游艇。我不确定这有多真实。
And this struggle in summer of 1924 seems perfectly poised. So let's just pause that here because we're in the middle of 1924. And don't forget, the clan is going to try and get involved in national politics and play the part of Kingmaker. Now, the clan has already been very successful. They've elected a senator from Texas. They've worn all sorts of public offices. and states as diverse, as we talked last time, as Oregon and in the northwest and Texas,
这场1924年夏天的斗争似乎处于完美的平衡状态。所以让我们在这里暂停一下，因为我们正处于1924年的中期。别忘了，三K党将试图参与国家政治并扮演“造王者”的角色。现在，三K党已经非常成功了。他们选出了一位来自德克萨斯州的参议员。他们担任了各种各样的公职。正如我们上次谈到的，在俄勒冈州、西北部和德克萨斯州等不同的州，
right down by the Mexican border. They have probably got about 16 senators in the U.S. Senate, loyal to the clan, and about 75 congressmen in the House of Representatives, and probably 11 governors. Again, loyal to the clan. These are Linda Gordon's figures. But what they really want to do
一直到墨西哥边境。他们在美国参议院可能拥有大约16名忠于三K党的参议员，在众议院拥有大约75名国会议员，可能还有11位州长。同样，忠于三K党。这些是琳达·戈登的数据。但他们真正想做的是
is to play a part in the presidential election. So the Republican candidate in the presidential election is Calvin Coolidge. He in some ways would be a suitable candidate for the clan. He's of Protestant stock going back to the Puritans in the 17th century. He's very clean living in all of this. But Coolidge hates the clan. He never made a public statement about them, but he is known to dislike them. He never knowingly appoints the Klansman to public office. And Coolidge supports black civil rights. And he goes out of his way to praise the contribution. that immigrants have made to American life.
在总统选举中发挥作用。所以总统选举中的共和党候选人是卡尔文·柯立芝。他在某些方面会是三K党的合适候选人。他有着可以追溯到17世纪清教徒的新教血统。他在所有这些方面都过着非常清洁的生活。但柯立芝讨厌三K党。他从未发表过关于他们的公开声明，但众所周知他不喜欢他们。他从不故意任命三K党成员担任公职。柯立芝支持黑人民权。他特意赞扬了移民对美国生活的贡献。
So he thinks basically the Ku Klux Klan are evil? Yeah, he thinks that, you know, a total scum. Yeah. So the clan then turn their attention to the Democrats, and they all go en masse to the Democratic Convention at Madison Square Garden in New York. Hiram Evans, the dentist, leads the clan leadership. And they know who they want to be the Democratic candidate,
所以他基本上认为三K党是邪恶的？是的，他认为他们是彻头彻尾的渣滓。是的。所以三K党随后将注意力转向民主党，他们集体前往纽约麦迪逊广场花园参加民主党全国代表大会。牙医海勒姆·埃文斯领导了三K党领导层。他们知道他们想要谁成为民主党候选人，
and he's actually the favorite. He is the son-in-law of Woodrow Wilson, who had praised the birth of a nation. This is a man called William Gibbs McAdoo. and Macadoo is the former US Treasury Secretary. Macadou is a huge fan of prohibition. He is the candidate, the champion of rural Protestant America. And standing against him for the Democratic nomination is the clan's worst enemy,
而且他实际上是热门人选。他是伍德罗·威尔逊的女婿，威尔逊曾赞扬过《一个国家的诞生》。这个人叫威廉·吉布斯·麦卡杜。麦卡杜是前美国财政部长。麦卡杜是禁酒令的忠实拥护者。他是农村新教美国的候选人、捍卫者。而站在他面前争夺民主党提名的是三K党最大的敌人，
their worst nightmare. Al Smith, the governor of New York, a Catholic. Oh my God, the horror. And the convention, it's the longest convention nominating process in American history. it took 103 ballots, 103 rounds of voting to get a winner. To the clan's delight, Al Smith does not win, but to their horror, William Gibbs-McCadoo doesn't win either.
他们最大的噩梦。阿尔·史密斯，纽约州州长，一名天主教徒。哦，天哪，太可怕了。这次大会是美国历史上最长的提名过程。它进行了103轮投票，103轮投票才选出获胜者。令三K党高兴的是，阿尔·史密斯没有赢，但令他们恐惧的是，威廉·吉布斯·麦卡杜也没有赢。
The convention compromises on the former ambassador to Great Britain who's called John W. Davis. No one needs to worry about him. He's completely forgotten. And what's worse for the clan is there's then a massive row about the clan itself. basically the anti-McCadoo people, the delegates, introduced a resolution to condemn the clan and it almost passed, it lost by four votes out of more than a thousand votes. And for the clan, this is a terrible shock.
大会在一位前驻英国大使约翰·W·戴维斯身上达成了妥协。没人需要担心他。他完全被遗忘了。更糟糕的是，对于三K党来说，关于三K党本身发生了一场巨大的争吵。基本上，反麦卡杜的人，代表们，提出了一项谴责三K党的决议，它几乎通过了，以四票之差输给了超过一千票。对于三K党来说，这是一个可怕的打击。
They're actually, they're not as influential in importance as they thought. So they're not kingmakers at all? They're not kingmakers after all. And as the convention breaks up and we go to the national election, which Coolidge ends up winning, The clan look at their membership roles, and their membership roles are beginning to fall, shockingly, because all the infighting means that a lot of ordinary clansmen are kind of lost confidence in the organisation. You know, they're all squabbling among themselves. They all look like they're really corrupt. There's so many revelations of bad behavior. Then when the people go to the poll, the American people go to the polls in November 1924, in Texas, which had been the, you know, it had been the great state where the clan had made their breakthrough.
他们实际上并不像他们想象的那样有影响力。所以他们根本不是造王者？他们毕竟不是造王者。随着大会解散，我们进入全国大选，柯立芝最终获胜，三K党查看他们的会员名单，他们的会员名单开始惊人地下降，因为所有的内斗意味着许多普通三K党成员对该组织失去了信心。你知道，他们都在互相争吵。他们看起来都非常腐败。有太多关于不良行为的揭露。然后当人们在1924年11月去投票时，美国人民去投票，在德克萨斯州，那曾是三K党取得突破的伟大州，
they'd got the senator in and whatnot. There is a backlash against the Klan. Their candidate for governor, their total disbelief, ends up losing. Anti-Klan candidates are elected across the board. The new Texas legislature passed a law against wearing masks. Klansmen are stripped of their public offices. They're driven out of the Democratic Party.
他们选出了参议员等等。出现了针对三K党的反弹。他们的州长候选人，在他们完全难以置信的情况下，最终输了。反三K党候选人全面当选。新的德克萨斯州立法机构通过了一项禁止戴面具的法律。三K党成员被剥夺了公职。他们被赶出了民主党。
And suddenly, membership of the Klan just drops off a cliff in Texas. So by 1926, the Klan lodges in Dallas, Houston, San Antonio and Fort Worth, which had been very, very popular, some of the most successful in the country have fallen so far they're in the hands of receivers. And membership in Dallas, a boom city for the clan in the early 20s, is down in just a couple of years from 13,000 people to barely 1,000 people. So the clan seems to be imploding, and then we get the scandal. So this is the story of Madge Oberholzer, which is, I have to warn us, it is.
突然之间，三K党在德克萨斯州的会员人数直线下降。所以到1926年，达拉斯、休斯顿、圣安东尼奥和沃斯堡的三K党分会，曾经非常、非常受欢迎，是全国最成功的一些分会，已经衰落到被接管的地步。达拉斯是20年代初三K党的繁荣城市，会员人数在短短几年内从13000人下降到仅1000人。所以三K党似乎正在内爆，然后我们遇到了丑闻。所以这就是玛奇·奥伯霍尔泽的故事，我必须警告我们，它是。
It's a pretty grim story, so prepare yourselves. Madge Oberholz, who enters the story of the clan on the 12th of January, 1925. She went to a party for the inauguration of the new Indiana governor, Ed Jackson, who was widely seen as the clan's puppet. And at this party, she met David C. Stevenson, the, what is it, the grand dragon? And what is match like? So Madge is 28 years old. She's very shy. She's not an especially socially dazzling person.
这是一个相当阴暗的故事，所以做好准备。玛奇·奥伯霍尔泽于1925年1月12日进入三K党的故事。她去参加了新任印第安纳州州长埃德·杰克逊的就职典礼，他被广泛视为三K党的傀儡。在这个聚会上，她遇到了大卫·C·史蒂文森，那个，是什么，大龙？玛奇是什么样的人？玛奇28岁。她很害羞。她不是一个特别善于社交的人。
She lives with her parents, Methodists. She runs the Indiana Young People's Reading Circle. So they start dating. They go, they dance and they start dating. On the 15th of March, Stevenson's secretary rang her parents' home. And she said, the Grand Dragon needs to see Madge at once. So she changed into her best black dress, and his bodyguard picked her up and drove off with her into the night. And she arrived at Stevenson's house to find him incredibly drunk.
她和父母住在一起，是卫理公会教徒。她经营着印第安纳青年阅读圈。所以他们开始约会。他们去跳舞，开始约会。3月15日，史蒂文森的秘书给她的父母家打了电话。她说，大龙需要立刻见玛奇。所以她换上了她最好的黑色连衣裙，他的保镖接上她，带着她驶入黑夜。她到达史蒂文森家时，发现他喝得烂醉。
And he and his men then forced her to drink loads of whiskey until she was sick. And then they hustled her into a car and took her off to Union Station, Indianapolis. And they put her onto the train to Chicago with Stevenson in Stevenson's private compartment. And she presumably is a virginal, god-fearing, upstanding spinster. Exactly. That's exactly what she is. Methodist home, lives with her parents, likes reading, all of that. The train sets off. And once the train sets off, she is now absolutely slaughtered because they forced her to drink all this whiskey. And he repeatedly rapes her. She's so drunk that she can't resist. And what is more, he bites her all over her body. So very deep bites. I mean, these are not,
他和他的手下强迫她喝了大量的威士忌，直到她呕吐。然后他们把她塞进车里，带到了印第安纳波利斯的联合车站。他们把她送上了去芝加哥的火车，史蒂文森在史蒂文森的私人包厢里。她大概是一个纯洁、敬畏上帝、正直的老处女。正是如此。她就是那样的人。卫理公会家庭，和父母住在一起，喜欢阅读，所有这些。火车出发了。火车一出发，她现在就彻底烂醉了，因为他们强迫她喝了所有这些威士忌。他反复强奸她。她醉得无法反抗。而且更重要的是，他咬了她全身。所以是非常深的咬痕。我的意思是，这些不是，
you know, these are serious bites like he is literally, it's said afterwards like he was literally trying to chew her. So from her kind of from her head all the way down to her. feet. They reached the town of Hammond, which is just outside Chicago, just on the Indiana side of the state boundary. And they get out there and check into her hotel. She's sort of being carried by his bodyguards. At one point, she says to Stevenson, I'm going to set the law on you, and he says to her, I am the law in Indiana. They go up to the room. He falls asleep. She persuades his chauffeur to take her out to a drugstore. And there she buys some mercury bichloride tablets, which were used then to treat syphilis.
你知道，这些是严重的咬痕，就像他事后被说的那样，就像他真的在试图咀嚼她。所以从她的头一直到她的脚。他们到达了哈蒙德镇，就在芝加哥郊外，就在州界的印第安纳一侧。他们在那儿下车，住进了一家酒店。她被他的保镖抬着。有一次，她对史蒂文森说，我要用法律制裁你，他对她说，在印第安纳州，我就是法律。他们回到房间。他睡着了。她劝说他的司机带她去一家药店。在那里她买了一些氯化汞片，当时用于治疗梅毒。
She wanted to kill herself. She was so horrified and ashamed about what had happened to her. She takes three of the tether. She intended to take the lot, but she could only swallow three, and immediately became horribly ill and started vomiting blood everywhere. Stevenson has now woken up from his drunken stupor, and he panics, and he says to his bodyguards, drive us back towards Indianapolis.
她想自杀。她对发生在她身上的事情感到非常恐惧和羞耻。她吃了三片。她本想全吃了，但她只能吞下三片，并立即变得非常难受，开始到处呕吐鲜血。史蒂文森现在从醉酒的昏迷中醒来，他惊慌失措，对他的保镖说，开车送我们回印第安纳波利斯。
In the car, she's in a terrible state, poor mad. She's being sick all over the car. Stevenson keeps saying to her, You must forget this. What's done is done. I am the law. I am the power. But clearly he's anxious because he keeps saying to her, we should stop and you should marry me, you know, because basically he wants to shut her up. And she says, I won't marry you and all this. And eventually, after a long delay, they take her home and they say to her parents who are horrified by the sight of her, or we've been in a car accident. Her parents are not fooled by this. And poor Madge, she lived for another month in terrible agony. And she died on the 14th of April. of infection from the bites, as well as kidney failure from the mercury poisoning. And by this point, her father had already gone to the police, and Stevenson was charged with rape, kidnapping, assault and battery, and second-degree murder. Murder because doctors testified in courts that the infected bites alone would have been enough to kill her.
在车里，她处于一种可怕的状态，可怜的玛奇。她吐得满车都是。史蒂文森一直对她说，你必须忘记这件事。过去的事就让它过去吧。我就是法律。我就是权力。但显然他很焦虑，因为他一直对她说，我们应该停下来，你应该嫁给我，你知道，因为基本上他想让她闭嘴。她说，我不会嫁给你，所有这些。最终，在长时间的耽搁后，他们把她送回家，并对她惊恐万分的父母说，哦，我们出了车祸。她的父母并没有被骗。可怜的玛奇，她在极度痛苦中又活了一个月。她于4月14日去世。死于咬痕感染，以及汞中毒导致的肾衰竭。到那时，她的父亲已经报了警，史蒂文森被控强奸、绑架、袭击和殴打以及二级谋杀。谋杀，因为医生在法庭上作证说，仅感染的咬痕就足以杀死她。
So it didn't require the mercury poisoning as well. Stevenson was convinced that his connections in Indiana meant that he would get off. He couldn't believe it when in November 1925 he was found guilty and sentenced to life in prison and sent to the Michigan City Penitentiary. And he believed that the governor, his puppet, Governor Jackson, would pardon him. But no pardon came. And eventually Stevenson loses patience and he gives all of his confidential papers to the Indianapolis Times. And he says to them, well, I'll tell you all about the bribes that I've paid to
所以不需要汞中毒。史蒂文森确信他在印第安纳州的关系意味着他会逃脱惩罚。当他在1925年11月被判有罪并被判处终身监禁并被送往密歇根市监狱时，他无法相信。他相信州长，他的傀儡，杰克逊州长，会赦免他。但赦免并没有到来。最终史蒂文森失去了耐心，他把所有的机密文件都给了《印第安纳波利斯时报》。他对他们说，好吧，我会告诉你们我支付给所有贿赂的事情。
local officials. And the result was an earthquake in Indiana politics. Up to this point, very heavily Republican. The scandal took down the governor of Indiana, the mayor of Indianapolis, the local head of the Republican Party, loads of state officials, loads of mayors, all of this kind of thing. And so it is that by the end of the decade, the Democrats had won pretty much every city in the state. And a disaster, not just for the Republicans, but for the local clan. One. One, the strongest in the nation, but the Stevenson scandal, the death of this poor woman, Madge Oberholzer, totally destroys the clan's image. So in two years, its Indiana membership collapsed from hundreds and hundreds of thousands of people to just 4,000 people. And what happens
当地官员。结果是印第安纳州政治的一场地震。到目前为止，非常亲共和党。丑闻拉下了印第安纳州州长、印第安纳波利斯市长、共和党当地负责人、大量州官员、大量市长，所有这些事情。所以到十年结束时，民主党几乎赢得了该州的每个城市。这是一场灾难，不仅对共和党人，而且对当地三K党也是如此。一个，全国最强大的，但史蒂文森丑闻，这个可怜的女人玛奇·奥伯霍尔泽的死，彻底摧毁了三K党的形象。所以两年内，其印第安纳州的会员人数从成千上万的人崩溃到仅4000人。发生了什么
to David Stevenson? He was released, I think, in 1950, if I recall correctly. He then got out. He then was arrested again, convicted again for sexually assaulting a 16-year-old girl. I think. So in and out of prison and then died, I think, in the 60s and the woman he was living with, possibly his wife, I can't remember, said, oh, he seemed such a nice person. I can't believe all these stories about him, were true. But clearly, an incredibly dodgy and unpleasant man. Died in 1966, age 74. So what happened to the clan in Indiana was a symptom of a wider story. In the mid to late 1920s, the clan absolutely hemorrhaged members. It had risen so quickly and then suddenly declines and historians have spent, you know, huge quantities of ink trying to explain why this is.
大卫·史蒂文森怎么样了？如果我没记错的话，他是在1950年被释放的。他然后出狱了。然后他再次被捕，再次因性侵一名16岁女孩而被定罪。我想是这样。所以进进出出监狱，然后我想在60年代去世了，和他住在一起的那个女人，可能是他的妻子，我不记得了，说，哦，他看起来是个很好的人。我不敢相信所有关于他的故事都是真的。但显然，一个极其狡猾和令人不快的人。1966年去世，享年74岁。所以印第安纳州三K党发生的事情是一个更广泛故事的症状。在1920年代中后期，三K党绝对流失了会员。它上升得如此之快，然后突然衰落，历史学家花费了大量的笔墨试图解释为什么会这样。
There are obvious underlying reasons as well as the scandals. The clan's vision was much too negative. It had nothing positive to, you know, it was all about hatred of Catholics and stuff more than anything else. Apart from some Anodyne stuff about patriotism and family values, most of its appeal is based on negativity. Its vision of America is an outdated one. You know, America by the 1920s is clearly much. too diverse to be turned back into a white Protestant enclave. That's never going to happen. Also, I think most historians think it was a terrible mistake for the clan to enter mainstream politics. The clan's values of secrecy and exclusivity don't work in a democratic arena
除了丑闻之外，还有明显的潜在原因。三K党的愿景太消极了。它没有什么积极的东西，你知道，它更多的是关于对天主教徒的仇恨。除了关于爱国主义和家庭价值观的一些平淡的东西外，它的大部分吸引力都基于消极。它对美国的愿景是过时的。你知道，到1920年代，美国显然太多元化了，不可能变回白人新教徒的飞地。那永远不会发生。此外，我认为大多数历史学家认为三K党进入主流政治是一个可怕的错误。三K党的秘密和排他性价值观在民主舞台上行不通。
where you have to make deals and compromises and you have to, you know, a pluralistic world in which you're appealing to bigotry and sectarianism. It doesn't work. There are some historians like Linda Gordon, who point out that actually maybe the clan stopped being so popular because it had actually won some of its battles. So the clan was always in favour of eugenics. And by the end of the 1920s, 30 American states had adopted eugenics laws with forced sterilization of criminals or people that were called defectives. And often the people who were singled out for this treatment tended to be very poor people or black people. So in other words, people that the clan didn't really like anyway. The clan also won the argument on immigration.
在多元化的世界里，你必须进行交易和妥协，而诉诸偏执和宗派主义是行不通的。一些历史学家，如琳达·戈登（Linda Gordon），指出三K党之所以不再那么受欢迎，可能是因为它已经赢得了一些斗争。三K党一直支持优生学。到20世纪20年代末，美国有30个州通过了优生学法律，对罪犯或所谓的“缺陷者”进行强制绝育。通常，被挑出来接受这种待遇的人往往是非常贫穷的人或黑人。换句话说，就是那些三K党本来就不喜欢的人。三K党在移民问题上也赢得了辩论。
So in 1924, the Johnson Reed Act brought in immigration quotas that were based on an outdated census, the 1890 census. So basically an immigration regime that tried to turn about the clock because 70% of immigrants under this new legislation had to come from Britain, Germany or Ireland. In other words, let's try to recreate a 19th century white America. All immigration from Asia, for example, was banned under the new legislation, and southern and eastern European immigration was severely curtailed. And this regime lasted until the 50s. And partly as a result of this, anti-Catholicism as a force in American life basically began to dissipate. So, you know, the Pope's plot to attack the people of North Manchester on the northbound train.
因此，1924年的《约翰逊-里德法案》（Johnson-Reed Act）引入了基于过时人口普查（1890年人口普查）的移民配额。基本上，这是一个试图倒转时钟的移民制度，因为根据这项新立法，70%的移民必须来自英国、德国或爱尔兰。换句话说，让我们试着重塑一个19世纪的白人美国。例如，新立法禁止了所有来自亚洲的移民，并严重限制了来自南欧和东欧的移民。这种制度一直持续到50年代。部分由于这个原因，作为美国生活中一股力量的反天主教情绪基本上开始消散。所以，你知道，教皇袭击北曼彻斯特北行火车上人们的阴谋。
By disguising himself as a corset salesman. Yeah, that never comes to fruition. You know, the clan has been saying for years, the Pope is poised to launch his attack. But the Pope never does. The uprising of armed Catholics never happens. And so people start, I think, over time to say to themselves, this is obviously demented. You know, this is never going to happen. and the clan just starts to sound a bit silly.
通过伪装成紧身胸衣推销员。是的，那从未实现。你知道，三K党多年来一直说，教皇准备发动袭击。但教皇从未这样做。武装天主教徒的起义从未发生。所以人们开始，我想，随着时间的推移对自己说，这显然是疯狂的。你知道，这永远不会发生。三K党开始听起来有点愚蠢了。
The other thing, of course, is the clan's violence. Things like the killings in Mare Rouge that we talked about, the reign of terror in Goose Creek, the murder of Madge Oberholzer, the vigilante violence in Williamson County. To most of the people who are there for the picnic and the barbecues, they're not up for all this. They're horrified by all this, actually.
当然，另一件事是三K党的暴力行为。比如我们谈到的马鲁日（Mare Rouge）杀戮事件、鹅溪（Goose Creek）的恐怖统治、玛奇·奥伯霍尔泽（Madge Oberholzer）的谋杀案、威廉姆森县（Williamson County）的治安维持会暴力事件。对于大多数参加野餐和烧烤的人来说，他们并不支持这一切。事实上，他们对这一切感到震惊。
And so once that becomes established in the public mind, people say, listen, I don't want to have anything to do with this organisation after all. So by the late 1920s, the numbers are in freefall. They've collapsed. And then the depression strikes. No one's got any money. You're not going to spend your money on collect tokens and ludicrous garb if you haven't got any money. The clan completely loses its mojo in the 30s. Hiram Evans, the dentist, is still running the clan. And he tries to rebrand it. He actually abandons the anti-Catholicism and says, we're an anti-communist group. We're anti-lab unions. That's what we're all about. But basically, no one's really.
因此，一旦这一点在公众心目中确立，人们就会说，听着，我不想再与这个组织有任何瓜葛了。所以到了20世纪20年代末，人数呈自由落体式下降。他们崩溃了。然后大萧条来袭。没人有钱了。如果你没钱，你不会把钱花在收集徽章和荒谬的服装上。三K党在30年代完全失去了魅力。牙医海勒姆·埃文斯（Hiram Evans）仍在经营三K党。他试图重塑品牌。他实际上放弃了反天主教立场，说我们是一个反共组织。我们反对工会。这就是我们的宗旨。但基本上，没人真的。
interested. He ended up resigning in 1939 as Imperial Wizard. You know, they'd done him no good at all. The clan to splintered and splintered, and then it disbanded in a very banal way for tax reasons. Now, of course, that's not the end of the clan or a clan as a feature of American life. So there is a third clan. And this was founded in 1946. At the same place as the second clan, the Stone Mountain, Georgia. this is the one that still exists. So this basically is anti-communist and intensely racist. It's well known because it carries out some hideous atrocities. So bombing of black churches in Birmingham, Alabama
感兴趣。他最终在1939年辞去了帝国巫师（Imperial Wizard）的职务。你知道，他们对他一点好处也没有。三K党分裂又分裂，然后因为税务原因以一种非常平庸的方式解散了。当然，这并不是三K党或作为美国生活特征的三K党的终结。所以有第三个三K党。它成立于1946年。地点与第二个三K党相同，在佐治亚州的石山（Stone Mountain）。这就是仍然存在的那个。所以这基本上是反共且极其种族主义的。它之所以出名，是因为它实施了一些可怕的暴行。比如在阿拉巴马州伯明翰炸毁黑人教堂。
and killing civil rights workers in 1963 and 1964. Some very famous examples. But it doesn't have many members. It's purely reactionary and racist. insofar as it thrives at all, it's in counterpoint to the civil rights movement, which is obviously much bigger than the Klan is. It's never remotely a mass movement. It still exists today, but it has, I think, fewer than 3,000 members, according to researchers. Was it David Duke? See, David Duke, everyone's heard of David Duke, but he was never a significant. It's his exoticism, I think, that makes him interesting. He's the kind of character. that Louis Theroux depends on for his TV programs. Kind of sinister, but not so sinister, that he wouldn't look ridiculous if he comes on a TV show.
并在1963年和1964年杀害民权工作者。一些非常著名的例子。但它没有多少成员。它纯粹是反动和种族主义的。它之所以能存在，是因为它与民权运动形成了对比，而民权运动显然比三K党大得多。它从来都不是一个群众运动。它今天仍然存在，但据研究人员称，它只有不到3000名成员。是大卫·杜克（David Duke）吗？你看，大卫·杜克，每个人都听说过大卫·杜克，但他从来都不是一个重要人物。我认为是他的异国情调让他变得有趣。他是那种路易·特鲁（Louis Theroux）在电视节目中依赖的角色。有点阴险，但又没那么阴险，以至于如果他出现在电视节目中也不会看起来很荒谬。
Exactly so. So today, I mean, they're much smaller than the oathkeepers or the proud boys. If you're a far right person, those are the groups you join in America, not the Ku Klux Klan. So that's the story of the second clan anyway. I think the second is by far the most interesting of the clans. I think the first is the most important because the first reverse is reconstruction or plays a part in reversing reconstruction.
正是如此。所以今天，我的意思是，他们比“誓言守护者”（Oath Keepers）或“骄傲男孩”（Proud Boys）小得多。如果你是一个极右翼人士，那些才是你在美国加入的组织，而不是三K党。所以这就是第二个三K党的故事。我认为第二个是三个三K党中最有趣的一个。我认为第一个是最重要的，因为第一个扭转了重建时期，或者在扭转重建时期中发挥了作用。
Could I just ask Dominic? We've done series on the Nazis, which, you know, it features people dressing up in uniforms and parading around at night and, you know, torchlit processions and holding things for families and combining a kind of schmaltzy sentimentality with extreme violence against Jews and so on. To the extent that there's a fascist party in America,
我能问一下多米尼克吗？我们做过关于纳粹的系列节目，你知道，它以人们穿着制服在晚上游行，你知道，火炬游行，为家庭举行活动，并将一种感伤的情绪与对犹太人的极端暴力结合起来。就美国存在法西斯政党而言，
would the clan be that fascist party, do you think? I think that's the interesting question. And I think that's what makes the 1920s clan the most interesting to me as a modern historian of the three. So the clan is not a European fascist party. It doesn't have a dynamic figurehead. It doesn't have a cult of the leader. They don't produce any leader of the caliber of the ruthlessness that European fascist parties do. The clan doesn't appeal to a kind of national irredentism.
你认为三K党会是那个法西斯政党吗？我认为这是一个有趣的问题。我认为这就是为什么20世纪20年代的三K党作为现代历史学家，对我来说是三个中最有趣的一个。所以三K党不是一个欧洲法西斯政党。它没有一个充满活力的领袖。它没有领袖崇拜。他们没有产生任何像欧洲法西斯政党那样具有冷酷无情素质的领袖。三K党不诉诸某种民族复仇主义。
You know, it doesn't say we have territories that have been taken from us by special. force. We must reassert ourselves internationally. Quite the reverse. The clan is quite isolationist. The clan is much less forward-looking, I think, than, for example, Italian fascism, more backward-looking. And the clan, of course, has no interest in war. They're just like riding around beating people up. Yes, they're like vigilante violence, but invading people fighting wars is not really part of their repertoire. But you're dead right, there are some huge similarities. So, victimhood, the family, hatred of the outsider, paramilitary violence, costumes, parades, rituals, torchlit processions, aeroplanes. Yeah, there are definite similarities. And for me,
你知道，它不说我们有被特殊武力夺走的领土。我们必须在国际上重申自己。恰恰相反。三K党相当孤立主义。我认为三K党比意大利法西斯主义等更不具有前瞻性，更具有倒退性。当然，三K党对战争毫无兴趣。他们就像骑着马到处打人。是的，他们就像治安维持会的暴力，但入侵他人、发动战争并不是他们手段的一部分。但你说得对，有一些巨大的相似之处。所以，受害者心态、家庭、对局外人的仇恨、准军事暴力、服装、游行、仪式、火炬游行、飞机。是的，确实有相似之处。对我来说，
I would say, there never has been a mass fascist movement in the United States. But if you want to imagine what one might have looked like, I think it would look not unlike the 1920s clan. Not least because actually the people, just think about it, demographically, the people who join the 1920s clan, and not dissimilar from the people who joined the National Socialist movement in 1920s, 1930s, Germany, Protestant, small businessmen, salesmen, you know, people who feel threatened by, they don't like, they're not members of labor unions, they're not very rich, they're not very poor, they feel squeezed, they feel anxious about change, you know, they like dressing up. Do you think the fondness for kind of galloping around on horses is a legacy of the World War?
我会说，美国从来没有过大规模的法西斯运动。但如果你想想象它可能是什么样子，我认为它看起来会和20世纪20年代的三K党没什么两样。尤其是因为实际上人们，想想看，从人口统计学上讲，加入20世纪20年代三K党的人，与加入20世纪20年代、30年代德国国家社会主义运动的人没什么不同，新教徒、小商人、推销员，你知道，那些感到受到威胁的人，他们不喜欢，他们不是工会成员，他们不是很富有，也不是很穷，他们感到被挤压，他们对变化感到焦虑，你知道，他们喜欢打扮。你认为对骑马奔跑的喜爱是世界大战的遗产吗？
the sense of people on horses going out there and imposing law and order, whether there is no law and order, and that that's a hangover because the Wild West is being romanticised in films at the same time as the Ku Klux Klan are. And it just becomes part of American mythology. Yeah, I think American mythology absolutely has a cult of the vigilante. Well, kind of Batman. Yeah, look at Batman. The man who rides into town to, because the useless authorities can't do it to clean up the town. And actually, you know, the reason it's so successful in, let's say, Indiana, is partly because Indiana had always had this tradition of vigilantes.
那种骑马出去维护法律和秩序的感觉，在没有法律和秩序的地方，这是一种宿醉，因为狂野西部在电影中被浪漫化，同时三K党也在被浪漫化。它只是成为了美国神话的一部分。是的，我认为美国神话绝对有一种治安维持者的崇拜。嗯，就像蝙蝠侠。是的，看看蝙蝠侠。那个骑马进城的人，因为无用的当局做不到，所以他来清理城市。事实上，你知道，它在印第安纳州如此成功的原因，部分是因为印第安纳州一直有这种治安维持者的传统。
You know, it was not that long since Indiana had been on the frontier, a generation, a couple of generations. So completely, yeah, that is not un-American. It is very American. And that's why, yeah, exactly as you say, that's why Batman's stories of masked vigilantes are so popular. You know, there's a comic book. I don't think you are a massive fan of comic books by Alan Moore called Watchmen in the 19th. Yeah, and they made it into a film. So there was then a TV series, which I have to say was brilliant, which departed from the comic book, but was all about the clan and superheroes and vigilantes.
你知道，印第安纳州处于边境并没有过去多久，也就一代人，几代人的时间。所以完全是这样，是的，那并非不美国。它是非常美国的。这就是为什么，是的，正如你所说，这就是为什么蝙蝠侠戴面具的治安维持者的故事如此受欢迎。你知道，有一本漫画书。我不认为你是艾伦·摩尔（Alan Moore）在19世纪创作的《守望者》（Watchmen）的超级粉丝。是的，他们把它拍成了电影。然后还有一部电视剧，我必须说非常精彩，它偏离了漫画书，但全是关于三K党、超级英雄和治安维持者的。
And it basically played with the similarities between superheroes dressing up in masks and going out to enforce order and racist paramilitary is doing the same. And in fact, the Tulsa massacre of 1921 played a big. part in that series. So yeah, I really recommend it actually. It didn't get the attention that should have done, but it's a brilliant, brilliant series. But anyway, that's enough of the clan, Tom, because I think we should do something totally different next time, because that's the beauty of the rest of history. So tell us what you have lined up for next week. So we will be going to medieval Japan to explore the emergence of the samurai. And you say completely different, But of course, the samurai are, they're people who like galloping around indulging in acts of violence.
它基本上玩弄了超级英雄戴着面具出去维护秩序与种族主义准军事组织做同样事情之间的相似之处。事实上，1921年的塔尔萨大屠杀（Tulsa massacre）在那个系列中发挥了重要作用。所以是的，我真的很推荐它。它没有得到它应有的关注，但这是一部非常非常精彩的系列剧。但无论如何，关于三K党就说这么多，汤姆，因为我认为我们下次应该做一些完全不同的事情，因为这就是历史其余部分的魅力所在。所以告诉我们你下周准备了什么。所以我们将前往中世纪的日本，探索武士的出现。你说完全不同，但当然，武士是那些喜欢骑马奔跑、沉溺于暴力行为的人。
And they're also incredibly mythologised. So this is a series that will explore how the shogunate emerges and replaces the traditional imperial order. But it is also a story that will feature flying heads and the ghosts of drowned samurai turning into crabs. So that will be on its way next week. And of course, if you are a member of the Rested History Club, then you will be able to get all four episodes of the samurai on Monday. And to join them, you just go to the restitisthistory.com and sign up there. And also, of course, we've got our sensational newsletter. And you can access that by replying to the email that features in the program notes to this series.
而且他们也被极度神话化了。所以这是一个将探索幕府如何出现并取代传统帝国秩序的系列。但这也是一个会有飞头和变成螃蟹的溺水武士鬼魂的故事。所以下周会有这些内容。当然，如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”（Rest Is History Club）的成员，那么你周一就能获得武士系列的所有四集。要加入他们，你只需前往 restisthistory.com 注册即可。当然，我们还有轰动性的时事通讯。你可以通过回复本系列节目说明中的电子邮件来访问它。
Dominic, thanks so much for an absolutely sweeping account of an organisation. very sinister, very dark. Thank you. Thanks everyone for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
多米尼克，非常感谢你对一个组织进行了如此全面的描述，非常阴险，非常黑暗。谢谢。谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。